The joe rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast,
my night,
all day.
All right,
we're live,
Billy Corbin,
what are you doing?
Any tweeting,
you're texting.
You can't fucking do that while we're online online.
I can do that all the time.
I realize it doesn't matter how much of my life I spend tweeting and and at this
point has been a significant percent and I've got,
I've got a cool little following,
but it did for what I dedicate and put into it.
I don't know that there,
the Roi is quite there,
right?
Especially when I can just sit back on my ass and my,
my phone just blows up when they go,
dude,
are you listening to Rogan?
He's talking about cocaine cowboys again.
It's like I don't have to tweet Joe,
take care of it.
But like,
seriously,
the feedback that I get and the love that I get from people,
you know,
your,
your audience,
your listenership is just off the charts.
Like the,
my,
my Twitter metrics dwarf in comparison to your listeners just hitting me up like
my family.
Like,
are you listening to Rogan?
Are you listening to Rogan?
I'm like,
right now I'm working in with like,
no,
you got it.
I'm like,
don't you work in?
And they're like,
no,
I'm listening to rogue and it will make a deal.
You keep making awesome fucking documentaries.
I'll keep talking about them.
They'll keep getting out there,
dude.
I like that deal.
That's it.
That's a hell of an arrangement as it went one day.
You got to do a live remote from Miami though.
This town.
Dude,
I got to tell you,
just like,
like Miami more than you like La Tally Miami more than I like more than I like
anything.
Uh,
honestly.
That's so weird.
Why is it,
cause you're smart.
Like you're really rare for a guy from Miami.
I've always said that if you want to starve to death,
open up a bookstore in Miami,
it's a great way to starve to death.
It's true.
Well anywhere and you'll starve to death.
Actually.
Now,
maybe a kindle,
a kindle store.
But like I,
well I,
I get this,
this town,
which has been incidentally nothing but good to me my whole life.
Um,
Los Angeles,
I mean like broken hearts of fuel,
the power grid and tears come out of the faucets.
Like I landed at lax,
I turn it to Raymond fucking Shandler all of a sudden I just like,
I get really sad here.
I don't know what it's the,
it's the fucking homeless guy and pretty woman screaming on Hollywood boulevard.
Like that's this,
that's this town to me.
Like just,
it's,
it's sad to me.
Miami is like,
I think Tony Montana said it best,
you know,
it's just a great big pussy waiting to be fucking correct.
Big posts.
Yeah.
Miami is the city of the future and always will be.
You know,
there's just like endless opportunity there,
but it never quite gets to that,
that level.
The,
the,
the famous saying is it like a la is where you go when you want to be somebody
in New York is where you go when you are somebody and Miami's where you go when
you want to be somebody else.
So,
and like that's the thesis of like all of our work in a way that's like the
motto of our company of Racking tour.
That's,
that's like,
it's too long to put on a tee shirt,
but it's like that's,
that's message.
That's the takeaway
I guess.
Not too long.
We put it on tee shirts on.
Be worked out.
Yeah,
a small font.
Good spacing.
Like we're designing it right now.
I could,
that could be worked on your water.
A preorder right now folks.
I mean I obviously like it here in a lot of ways.
What I don't like here is the amount of humans.
There's,
there's just your quantity,
overwhelming supply of human beings here to the point that I think that anytime
you get too many people in one place,
you devalue those people.
It's like,
I think that's the case with everything.
I mean,
I think if you're a guy,
you have a million fucking girlfriends,
they're all waiting for you in a warehouse.
You're not going to care if one of them dies.
You know?
You're just not,
you're just not,
you're barely gonna care.
If you,
if you have an airplane hangar filled with tens and you just walk in and you go,
you in the back with the yellow hair come this way,
please your,
that's your,
it doesn't mean anything.
If you have one wife that you love dearly,
it's going to mean a lot more if something happens to her.
I think La has too many fucking people and I think the,
when you get too many people you,
there's this sort of weird things that happens where you stop caring about them.
He,
they don't mean anything to you,
but he's 28 years at quality.
Well,
there's too many.
The quality is here.
There's a lot of people that they're very important because we're all,
we're all to be fair.
The center of our own universe.
I mean,
but like everybody,
like everybody,
I don't,
I don't want to say I,
I realized there's no other way to say this other than how it's going to sound,
but like the self worth meter is off the charts for way too many people.
It is,
but it's also a fake meter.
Like people are like holding up a meter of what they're pretending they're self
worth is.
But in reality,
what they really think about themselves,
they're incredibly insecure,
which is why they're here trying to validate themselves in the first place.
This,
this is a weird town in that everybody who comes here wants to be someone
special and usually they want to be someone special because they weren't special
when they were children.
So they get here,
you seek out this,
this ultimate thing,
which is fame and now because of people like Kim Kardashians and reality shows,
you don't even have to do anything for it.
Anything.
You don't have to have a special talent.
Troubling thing to me it you know what to put in work any more manifested itself
with this like Kanye deck thing.
It's like Beck.
I mean you can't really ask for more gifted musician or songwriters for,
it's like artistry is concerned.
You could see what you can be subjective about it.
You could say you like him,
you don't like him,
but the guys in artists,
I mean legitimate.
He puts in the work he played.
He writes everything.
He plays every,
every frag and instrument on his,
on his album.
So it's like the guys putting in the work and why d value somebody who was
actually an accomplished writer artist and say like,
well,
his art isn't worth as much as somebody else's art or Kanye West has a real ego
problem.
He needs psychedelics more than anyone I've ever seen.
The public,
I mean,
he's such a insufferable Douche bag and that's because
his ego is completely out of control.
He wants people to pay attention to him.
He wants to be loved.
He wants to be great.
That's his big thing.
Leave me alone.
Let me be great.
You know,
you fucking rhyme shit surrounded,
but that's it.
No,
no offense just to his handlers,
but like you're surrounded by awful people.
Those,
the people are supposed to keep you in check and give me some perspective on
your place in the universe,
which is only smaller than you can't do that.
They don't,
that's not their job.
Their job is to make money.
And the way they make money is to keep like rubbing his back and pushing them
out there in the ring.
I mean that,
that's it.
Keep,
keep getting them to make more money.
Jewish people.
We have our families to both like blow up our heads and also put us right back
in our place.
I remember I got into some trouble a couple of years ago.
I was on a jury.
I was the jury foreman in a criminal case in Miami Dade Circuit Court.
And,
uh,
it was an armed robbery case and I tweet it because that's what I do.
I didn't tweet about the case,
but I did my usual shit of just kind of observations of the courthouse.
I noticed that it was a,
it was named for this guy,
Richard Gerstein,
who was a state attorney who had,
uh,
had rumored ties to Meyer Lansky later represented peewee Herman in his,
indecent exposure case in Florida,
you know,
when he was in the,
jerking off in the adult theater.
And,
um,
just thinking about,
I could see from the window in the jury pool room,
I was like,
how,
you know,
how appropriate that,
that the view from the jury room and the in the criminal courthouse is one of
the greatest crimes perpetuated on the people of Miami Dade,
which was the Marlins Park,
the publicly financed,
you know,
sports welfare,
Boondoggle of,
of Miami,
Marlins Stadium,
Baseball Park.
And so ignorant to that,
we'll get back to that.
But I like just tweeting stupid observational shit.
And then my usual sort of aggregating articles.
So this comes up on appeal that public defender,
we can victim of a lesser included offense.
The public defender says,
oh,
the jury foreman was tweeting,
like live tweeting the trial,
which is not what happened.
I didn't delete anything.
All my tweets are still there.
So the Miami Herald like rips me,
they have this completely talent free,
a writer at the Herald.
She actually slept her way to the middle is what she did.
She slept with her married editor and got a promotion and it was a whole
scandal.
Really?
Yeah.
And,
and the,
and now I call her America and Cuba's worst columnist and she still has a job.
It's,
it's unbelievable.
And she like rips me for being a,
what was it like tweeting Twitter?
That's what she called me,
a tweeting twit and my,
my,
my parrot won't shit on the Herald.
You know what?
I line its cage with it.
So like the Herald's masthead is like Miami Herald,
uh,
yesterday's news,
tomorrow corrections to follow.
That's their shtick.
So like Mike,
but my grandpa old school,
they still read the newspaper,
you know,
he likes the ink on his fingers.
And so he reads this like vicious column about,
about me,
about his grandson.
And his takeaway is this,
he's like,
this is a few years ago.
So he says,
he says to me,
he goes,
how many Twitter followers do you have?
And I was like,
a bat at the time was like maybe 10,
maybe 10,000.
I was like,
I don't know about 10,000.
He goes,
just in Bieber is 22 million.
And that was it.
I just felt like shit.
Like he put me right back.
I was reminded of my place in the universe with one with that,
which I said,
first of all,
how the hell does my grandfather,
and I didn't even know that it goes pretty irrelevant,
but grandfather sounds like a dick.
I'm going to be honest with you.
He's a GRANDPA.
He's a wonderful man.
He's a wonderful,
wonderful man.
He is.
That's all he had to say.
Just no neighborhoods.
He didn't say to me like,
I'm ashamed of you and what you did and this woman destroying you in the
newspaper.
He was like,
he was pretty cool with that.
He was just,
he was just trying to understand this Twitter thing a little bit better.
That's all.
He's still not on it though.
That's funny though.
Well,
yeah,
I mean that having someone in your life to keep you in check like that is
important.
Or having something,
you know,
I don't think he has anything to keep them in check,
which is why he thinks it's funny to go on stage and interrupt people's
performances or,
or acceptance speeches.
No mother voting.
Why don't they just like Kanye pick who wins everything.
That was.
How about this?
How about the Emmys are stupid.
How about the Oscars are stupid.
They're all stupid or award shows for art or dumb.
They really are because art is incredibly subjective.
You know this and this idea that you're going to have this one big moment where
everybody dresses up like a penguin and you all get together and pretend that
this is our night to shine,
shine for.
It's got to make a living too.
Dude,
who's top,
he just liked the Tux is like Justin Timberlake.
He does tuxes is kind of like his shtick.
He's a fashion designer,
but like I,
I'm not a big,
everybody always,
I often get introduced or like people like a write up a bio or blurb on me,
they'll be like award winning filmmaker.
I'm like,
I don't actually think I've won any awards awards.
I guess we have along the way.
Like I got it.
I got a key to the city of Miami and Miami Beach,
which was incredibly disappointing because when you know you're in Miami beach
and somebody gives you a key,
right?
You're kind of hoping it's going to be something else if you,
if you hear what I'm screaming,
but uh,
the,
it was not the kind of key that you hope to get when you go to Miami.
He low.
Yes.
It's one of your,
when you explain it.
I think so.
Well it didn't work unless you did that.
I think there's a few listeners that got it.
Maybe two that are
keys.
Mine.
There's only,
there's only,
there's only two listeners coked up right now.
I don't think that's true.
There's more than two,
but they're the only ones that got that show.
What we were talking about before about what's wrong with this town,
and this is probably the last time we should get into it because this is like
such a tired subject,
but the,
the idea that people who didn't get enough attention when they were young,
so they developed this hole in their soul.
They need to fill up at other people's attention.
They come here and then they seek validation through auditioning,
which is one of the most ridiculous processes ever.
I mean the idea that you're going to be in line with a bunch of other people
hoping to get picked and if you do get picked like yes,
yes,
it's me.
I'm going to be the one and then you're the one who's going to get there and
then the camera's on you and they put makeup on you to make it pretty and
perfect lighting and it's all these,
it's this weird thing.
Then if you're lucky,
you can get through that with some sense of what you're trying to do in the
first place,
which is like trying to create something cool that people enjoy and then some
sense of humility where you kind of understand that that's in the greater
spectrum of the universe.
It's really not that significant.
What it is is it gets a lot of attention because we're confused and media
confuses people and the idea of the one,
the Alpha with the light on them and the one who has the microphone and the one
who has the voice and that this is somehow or another makes you special,
but it doesn't.
It's just entertainment.
Well does she thinks I had to say about the first of which is that I'm going to
put it out there.
I don't talk about it that much,
but I'm gonna put it out there because I think step one in the program is
admitting that you have a problem.
So I was a child actor.
Oh,
not in this,
in this town and this town.
And that's your problem.
I wished that there was,
yeah,
but it was very good to me.
It was very good to me.
I was very successful and end before I retired at 15 or whenever or whatever it
was.
But like,
it,
uh,
first of all I wished there was a different term other than child actor,
which g,
which immediately evokes images of like liquor store robberies,
drug overdoses and child molestation.
But like,
but that's what I was,
um,
the second thing I want it,
I want to say,
which I probably shouldn't talk about because you mentioned it when you're
talking about the casting process and,
um,
and how completely toxic that is,
uh,
in terms of creating anything of substance.
And it's not just,
it's this development process.
We,
we,
we optioned the rights to develop a dramatic series about cocaine cowboys about
I think eight years ago now with Bruckheimer television,
Michael Bay and one or horizons.
And we had been developing the show,
developing development,
developing,
you know,
when you say a word so much or you look at it so often it loses its meaning and
you kind of have to look like what does this word means?
Something development.
So we're on a call one down there.
This is already years ago,
it was years into development and years ago already.
That's how long we've been developing this.
And I'm looking at,
we're on a conference call,
you can't get a word in edge wise,
really on a conference call.
So I'm listening to this call and I'm looking at at the,
at the calendar and it says JB TV development call and I'm staring at the word
and it loses its meaning.
So I kind of,
you know,
the,
the voices turned into,
you know,
peanuts,
adults won't want Wah,
Wah,
Wah Wah.
And I open a new tab in my browser and I go to dictionary.com I probably should
have got an urban dictionary.com and I go to dictionary.com and I look up the
word development and I realize looking at the definition that the development
process in film and Television and there to entertainment is the antithesis of
the definition of the word development,
which infers progress,
evolution.
And it's the exact opposite of that.
If it doesn't stifle progress it,
it actually has a reverse.
It's like d evolution.
It's like an development or d development.
I don't know what the term is,
but it's a total misnomer.
A you this,
this idea of developing cause like we want to make a documentary,
we get an idea or someone comes to us and we have access to a cool person or a
great story and we,
I got two partners.
It's me and two guys.
One Guy I've known,
I've known so long,
our parents used to bathe us together.
I mean we were sophomores in high school.
That was weird.
But like,
uh,
no,
we were nursery school.
We were in,
I know the guy literally since nursery school or other partner outfront
Spellman,
I know him from television production in middle school.
So we look at each other and go,
does this sound like a cool idea?
Yeah,
let's do it.
That's our development in the nonfiction world.
This whole like scripted thing where like you bring in three writers and you pay
them untold amounts of money and they're from Santa Monica with Nannies and
they're going to write for the Miami drug scene in the late seventies.
You're like,
what is going on here?
How is this progress?
How are we developing anything here?
And in terms of our warped values and media manipulating w w w our priorities,
nothing breaks my heart more than when I tweet something important that's going
on in the world and it gets like two retweets or whatever.
And then you tweet something about Kim Kardashians or Justin Bieber or Kanye
West or Bruce Jenner,
God forbid.
And it just,
it gets,
uh,
it gets 1200 retweets or some crazy Florida man story that gets 10,000 retweets
and,
and it breaks my heart because I'm just like,
I'm like,
I'm contributing to the distraction.
Here is what I feel like and,
and,
but I,
it really frustrates me.
It's like,
what's something about,
you know,
uh,
the lack of accountability in politics or the public sector or,
you know,
the,
the dramatic increase in police and police brutality and the prison population
as the,
the crime rate drops precipitously.
All these things that we should kind of be concerned about as a people.
And I just realized,
I was like,
maybe I need to take my own advice and like the,
the fact that we're all so insignificant and so small and this time is so
fleeting,
why not just have a good time while we're here?
We're not actually gonna change anything for the better.
It's like that saying,
what's it saying?
It's like,
ah,
I want to have less corruption or more participation in it or something.
Like,
it's like that's how as I get older I feel like,
well,
what were were,
where am I getting here?
Why not,
you know,
I,
I'm not actually going to affect,
shoot any positive change.
Maybe a little,
maybe a little bit of awareness in my corner of the Twitter verse,
but w w which don't,
I just need to do something for myself,
for my family and I can't do that.
There's like something,
there's a moral compass that just won't let me kind of like compromise my values
and in a weird way,
I hate that about myself.
Just relax man.
Seriously do smoke weed.
No,
you should probably,
it would help you alone.
That's the diagnosis.
Well,
you guys have medical marijuana here for,
for Biloxi.
For Fuck's sake,
dude.
I fought my ass off for amendment two in Florida.
We got nearly 58% of the vote and it failed.
[inaudible] 62 right?
Scott,
the least popular governor in the history of anything,
anywhere.
Okay.
Gets 47% of the vote in four more years to destroy the state of Florida.
Like,
but we have too many old people.
Too many old people.
It's demonstrating,
yeah,
they,
their idea of what marijuana is just completely fucked by propaganda or elected
officials fortunately are kind of realizing that like,
wait a second,
if you look at the,
the,
the district results for amendment to,
they're going,
well,
shit,
my constituents want this.
So now you do have some local politicians who are trying to,
and state politicians who are trying to introduce bills now that will,
uh,
that will bring medical marijuana to the state of Florida.
Because what they're trying to do is beat 2016 where met,
not only is it a,
you know,
is it a presidential elections of turnout?
Turnout in Florida could be as much as,
I don't know,
12%.
Why don't people vote?
Well,
they feel discouraged.
They don't think it works.
You look at the system itself.
You look at special interest groups and lobbyists and the amount of money that
corporations donate towards campaigns to mobilize,
not just to impact how people are going to vote,
but just to get people going out to vote.
If you,
one thing's for sure,
if you don't vote,
your votes not going to be counted.
I can guarantee,
I can guarantee that.
Right.
So the special interest money really goes towards mobilizing people who are
already in a way like minded,
like you said,
like the elderly population and which is really what helped kill I think,
recreational marijuana here or the expansion of marijuana laws in California.
It was,
it was,
you weren't quite there yet.
People weren't,
I think getting out,
not getting out the vote per se,
but,
but they weren't convincing the elderly population who by the way probably need
marijuana even more than I do.
Um,
just in terms of their,
you know,
their metal,
their maladies,
it probably would do more for them and certainly in Florida do more for them.
But some of them are still on that,
you know,
that Hippie drug thing?
Yeah.
That's what they think it is.
Which is,
which doesn't make any sense.
Not to mention what could any governor or any politician or anybody in this
country do and the single stroke of a pen that would create the kind of economy
that that brings.
How do you create jobs?
You know that many jobs and that kind of revenue in the marijuana,
marijuana,
the marijuana and there's nothing else I could possibly think of that you could
do where you can say like overnight we could just create an epic industry that
not only hurts no one but helps millions of people and more importantly
decriminalizes a class of people in this country that we have needlessly spent
untold millions of dollars to deprive them of life,
liberty and property.
And you're right,
I need to smoke.
Like just give me like a fucking brown or some money.
They're making Colorado so staggering.
They have to give it back to the taxpayers and you read that the refunds,
yet they're giving people money back.
Too much money for education.
Now they are literally making untold millions of dollars in tax revenue that
would be unavailable otherwise and most likely the same amount of people are
smoking weed,
which just lets you know that this is just really an inefficient use of,
of public resources.
Does the inefficient use of a commodity,
which is unnatural commodity.
That's a part of life.
I mean marijuana is a God damn plant that's been used for thousands of years in
Florida.
We had a pill mill crisis.
No.
Yeah,
the likes that we have.
I mean I had that,
that did that documentary.
Um,
the uh,
the oxycontin express.
Oh yeah.
Great.
Amazing.
I think it was up to seven people a day were dying in the state of Florida.
These are some,
we mean children.
It's not enough.
You should kill more.
You guys should have opened up more coal plants in new spots in Florida.
Too many people maybe in the north.
I prefer the,
you know they say in Florida,
the further north you go,
the further south you are and you forget that like Florida,
I mean this was like Jim Crow,
south Florida.
South Florida is like a tropical country.
It's like the only way I can compare it to people who might get some percent.
It's like Atlanta in Georgia.
Yes.
Kind of south Florida is like,
cause we're still very much a red.
We're like a red state with a blue for skin that everybody wishes they could
just circumcise like right off the state.
And in fact the city of South Miami is interesting thing about Miami Dade.
Nobody even knows this.
Miami Dade County,
which has about I think 2.6 million people now we're made up of like 34
different municipalities.
So there's a total of like 35 different mayors in just Miami Dade County.
And the city of Miami is just one small city among the 34 in Miami Dade County.
And in fact,
Dade County get this used to be called Dade County or Metro Dade County in 97 we
rebranded,
we voted to change the name of the,
of the town.
Like where else other than like Bombay and Mumbai,
like you think of a place that like changes the name.
We rebranded it to Miami Dade County to borrow essentially the most famous brand
that we have,
which is the most famous city in,
in the area.
And so one of these cities,
these 34 municipalities,
we have 34,
34 municipalities and I think to be fair only there's still 30 of them who
haven't had their mayor arrested yet in the last two years.
So that's a,
that's a pretty good ratio.
But the city of south Miami actually,
they had like a resolution to uh,
essentially succeed,
not secede from the union,
but split Florida down the middle into two separate states in north Florida or
north and south,
uh,
south Florida to this day.
Great,
great idea.
For Real.
It's a great,
it'll never happen because south Florida's revenue is what finances Tallahassee,
which is the state capital,
which is an in the panhandle in northern Florida.
So that'll never happen because they,
they,
they live off the fat of our land and our tourism trade.
So that'll never happen.
But it's a great idea.
When you look at the politics,
when you look at the demographics and,
and,
and how,
sort of the way that people,
the thought process,
we are very much two different,
two different states.
South Florida is more democratic.
It's more liberal,
the blue tip.
But there's a lot of Cubans that are very Republican,
right?
A lot of conservative ever since Kennedy and the Bay of Pigs,
they,
they took a hard,
a hard,
right.
I mean,
there,
there are Cubans who have not voted Democrat since Kennedy,
but you're seeing now a new generation,
third and fourth generation Cubans who are now being actually born in Miami.
Uh,
you see this trend changing.
Miami used to go to Miami and,
and just say,
really anywhere in Florida,
where are you from?
And even if people were there for 60 years,
they'd go Cuba,
Chicago,
Philadelphia,
New York,
know no one was from Miami.
That's changing now.
You see a little bit of this three Oh five til I die.
This kind of like,
you know,
the spirit of like,
uh,
the spirit of like ownership of belonging,
which I keep hoping it's going to manifest itself in people driving better and
using their turn signals and being nicer to each other.
I keep trying to say it's not Miami or your Emmy,
it's our Emmy.
This is a collective experience here.
People,
let's say we're in this together,
let's just be nicer,
nicer to each other.
But like you're a Miami fan boy.
I am.
I'm a homeboy and I get homesick when I traveled to like,
I'm like,
I,
I miss it.
Especially when I go Ellie's different cause it's not homogenized.
But when I travel around to places where it like I'm like,
I'm nervous.
There's too many white people here.
Like,
I need some Odos Campolo and in some Catholic or Lecce like I get nervous when,
when there's not,
you know,
when there's like a homogenized population,
I don't like to mix it up.
I don't know Miami because Miami,
like you just,
you're driving,
you can drive a stretch of blocks in Miami beach and you go from the Argentinian
neighborhood to the Venezuela neighborhood of the Brazilian neighborhood.
I should say this,
there's a common misconception that Miami is a melting pot.
We are not a melting pot.
We are more akin to like a TV dinner where sometimes the piece fall over into
the mashed potatoes because we self segregate.
We do that anywhere we go is people,
you know,
we find likeminded or Chinatown,
similar looking people and we,
and we stick to our own.
So in Miami,
you know,
you have the Jewish neighborhood,
you have a,
uh,
you know,
a Haitian neighborhood.
You have an African American neighborhood and go,
you have a Cuban neighborhood of Cuban neighborhood of Cuban neighborhood of
Cuban neighborhood.
You have.
Um,
then like I was saying in Miami Beach,
even you have than a Swayla Brazil,
Brazilian neighborhood,
they don't,
you know,
even the South Americans,
which is the thing they hate the most,
is like being called Latin Hispanic.
They're very prideful and nationalistic people.
They want to be associated with their nation,
their actual,
you're getting into an argument and anybody in Miami on until you see what flag
is hanging from the rear view mirror because God forbid,
dude,
you should call an Argentinian Venezuelan,
a Venezuelan,
a Cuban,
uh,
a Brazilian they get,
or any of them are Mexican,
they all hate Mexicans for or for some reason.
And then,
I don't know.
But they,
and all of them,
if you ask any of them,
they'll tell you,
oh my great bro.
Like,
like for truth,
Bro,
like seriously.
Like my great,
great grandfather is from Spain.
They all claim they're European.
Then none of them are Caribbean.
They're all European.
It's,
it's kind of fun.
And I like that.
That kind of in Cindy Arie mix of people,
you know,
and like 1980 it was like,
which is kind of the inspiration cooking cowboys.
It was like that year we're like all of the chemicals just mixed together and
shit just exploded.
And that's your,
there's that tension in Miami constantly that that I think is just,
it just makes it an exciting,
exciting place.
Particularly when anybody outside of Miami and they think there's only like one
hotel,
the colony on ocean drive because wherever you are in Miami,
all,
you know,
is it like 15 blocks of ocean drive,
you know?
And,
and even when you watch Miami dolphins games or like the orange bowl game,
which is at Joe Robbie Stadium are now sunlife stadium in Miami Gardens,
one of the most dangerous municipalities in my immediate one most dangerous
neighborhoods in the world is Miami Gardens.
That's where the stadium is located.
They'll crossfade from the game to the blimp,
aerial of the stadium and then we'll cross fade to ocean drive as if that's
right outside.
It's 18 miles away from the stadium.
And,
but that's what people associate with Miami.
Most of Miami is third world.
Ian,
I mean,
Miami Dade County has one,
I think only the second greatest disparity in income gap in the key of any major
county in the country.
We are,
you know what,
what did the,
uh,
TD Allman had a book,
called,
um,
city of the future about Miami that,
you know,
they say that dot.
Like,
the Florida of today is the America of tomorrow.
And if you want to know what shit is gonna go down in America,
what calamities are going to befall this country in like the next 20 years or
so?
You look at what's going on in Miami or Florida,
that is the barometer of whether it's the drug trade,
immigration,
what we're dealing with,
with,
with now,
with the,
you know,
the,
the Browning of America,
if you will,
they span a sizing of America.
And the pushback we've been through all of that shit.
Medicare fraud,
uh,
you name it,
we have experienced it already in,
in Miami,
or are in flow,
the Greater Florida area.
And,
and we know what's coming basically.
Sure.
Oh yeah.
We got everything but earthquakes in mud slides.
How did you get involved with this documentary?
Cocaine cowboys.
What was the,
what was the inspiration to make this?
Just knowing the history of how crazy Miami was and what,
what led to this massive surge of drugs into that part of the country?
What was her childhood in a weird way?
I mean,
we grew up in Miami.
I was born in a place called Fort Myers,
Florida on the,
uh,
on the west coast.
So you lived out here when you do a couple of years,
you know,
for,
for like five pilot seasons or whatever the hell you do.
Did your parents bring you out here to do them?
I,
yeah,
I asked them to.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I asked him to.
Wow.
So it wasn't even that you had stage parents?
It was all yo,
dude,
every year my parents would say to me enough,
whenever you're done.
Yeah.
They would say,
whenever you're done.
That's just like that.
That's dead ringer for oddly from my dad.
Uh,
he's transitioning now.
That was weird
transitioning you.
She can say that a few years ago,
no one would know what the fuck you're talking about,
but you say he's transitioning now.
It's like,
is here this like overwhelming influx of transgender people in our culture?
Is I what's going on?
Or,
or we're just more aware of it I guess.
And you are,
and it's kind of okay.
I mean,
like gay people got married in Alabama this week.
It's a new world man.
Like it's Internet.
It's,
it's,
it's kind
of fantastic.
Like I'm like when I was traveling,
we were on set of this pilot,
uh,
in,
in Puerto Rico.
And while I was on the plane,
there was no internet on,
on,
on this slide because we're coming from Puerto Rico for whatever reason.
And so as soon as I landed a,
Obama had announced the new Cuba policy and I landed in Miami while this was
going on in the air.
And,
um,
no one really knew exactly how Miami was gonna react.
The truth is,
a lot of the hard line,
older conservative Cubans have died off.
The demographic is changing.
There are Cuban kids growing up now who don't want to never get to see Cuba
before they die.
Like a lot of their grandparents never got to end.
Great grandparents ever got to go back.
So the sentiment was very different from whatever like from circa Ellian
Gonzales that was like the last gasp of you know,
eggs,
right wing exile a a politics was really the Elian Gonzales a fiasco.
And so this,
this was a little bit calmer but like I landed and I was like I just landed in a
whole new world.
Like it was an incredible and and whether you agree with policies or not,
it's kind of cool to see when you're hyper aware of that,
like history is happening in your lifetime and before your eyes.
And that's what Miami was like in the 1980s and growing up we were even aware of
it when I was most aware of it as a kid was the money we worked at.
We were,
we lived in this like working class Jewish neighborhood in north Miami beach and
everybody was doing good.
They weren't in the drug business per se,
but this is the best is the most successful case study in history for Ronald
Reagan's trickle down economics theory because there was so much cash in Miami
and it trickled down to everyone.
Whatever business you were in,
you were making more cash,
you were willing to the drug trade because of the drug trade.
There was so much cash tourism.
By 1980 tourism was art and real estate.
They were like our top businesses.
Tourism was bringing in about five point $2 billion a year in Miami drugs.
They're estimating was generating $7 billion a year,
so it was an even bigger business than tourism in,
in,
in that in the early 1980 so you just had,
it was just everywhere.
Like in our neighborhood,
people added like made additions to their houses.
They had like a Porsche or a nicer car and these are people who were,
jewelers are in the grocery business or car dealers are just working people.
But suddenly everybody was a little,
was a little flush and they weren't upgrading in a major way.
They were just getting themselves some toys that they could get with the fruits
of,
of this new found a of this,
the fruits of their labor in this new found a revenue generating cash and was
just,
and you've heard the stats about,
you know,
from the movie about,
the,
uh,
the branch of the Federal Reserve in,
in Miami had a cash surplus of more money than all the branches combined in the
country.
That was just more cash.
Am I mean,
nobody had any place to put it.
What you saw in Scarface when banks were charging a vague to deposit cash,
that was true.
They had no place to put cash.
There was just too much cash.
And it's true that if you took a $20 bill or done a denomination of 20 or above
cash in Miami and tested it,
there were traces of cocaine on almost every single bill in Miami.
It was so,
it was literally trug money.
That's amazing.
It's an amazing time.
And your documentary really captures it so brilliantly.
It just with the,
when,
when you highlighted that that one graduating class of the police academy,
that every single guy either went to jail or was murdered every single one.
I mean that,
that's an amazing moment in human history where you just get to see essentially
it's a version of what's going on in Mexico right now.
Oh,
absolutely.
And,
and,
and it's actually a version interestingly,
of what's going on in the United States in terms of hiring practices and better
screening people in law enforcement and people in the public sector in general.
Because what happened there is that you didn't have good people who became cops
and then the power went to their head and they became corrupt or anything like
that.
You had,
you had gangsters,
straight up thugs who decided,
well,
where better to apply my trade then be hiding behind a badge.
That's what happens with these weren't like,
this is why these were,
these were bad guys who,
who it became.
We had a,
um,
what happened was there was a federal judge,
there was a consent decree,
a federal judge who was a civil rights action.
A federal judge looked at the demographics,
the changing demographics of Miami and said there's basically 100% of the Miami
police department was white and they said you need a police force that better
represents the community that they're policing.
And so it was a federal judge who just waived,
waived his,
his,
his magic pen and said,
hire more black officers,
higher far,
far more of Hispanic officers.
So you have a police to force that that reflects the community,
their there and what happened,
I hate to say it,
but it's true.
They kept reducing the standards for hiring and that's what happened is that
they wound up with guys who were like,
wait,
I'm on the streets,
I'm a straight up gangster,
but the Miami police are hiring.
Like that's what happened.
So really the system worked in a way and that they read it out,
you know,
the,
the worst of them.
And that's,
I think it's a little bit,
I thinking by and large you have a lot of good cops now.
But the problem is,
is that they're not screening,
they're not sufficiently screening in the hiring process to say cereal.
Oh,
I think so.
All over the country.
I think you've got guys who are sort of naturally aggressive.
You have a steroid epidemic in the police departments that are,
that the unions have,
have completely precluded,
uh,
municipalities from being able to test officers.
Um,
I think you have,
again,
an epidemic that affects a certain minority or percentage of officers and
departments,
but it's still an issue that you don't want guys like that with,
you know,
with the ability to,
to deprive people of life,
liberty and property.
Yeah.
The steroid thing is absolutely legit.
I got pulled over by a dude who looked like Ronnie Coleman,
who by the way was a police officer,
Ronnie Coleman,
who was Mr was a police
officer.
I mean,
he might,
I don't know that,
I don't know if he still is,
but yeah,
I mean,
he was a long time police officer,
but this guy that pulled me over was,
it was ridiculous.
And,
uh,
we,
we had a nice little chat,
you know,
he's a nice guy.
He's a fan.
Yeah,
he was a good guy.
But I mean this dude was choosed.
He was,
I mean five,
nine,
two 70 somewhere around then,
which doesn't happen in nature unless you're a fucking gorilla.
I mean,
it just doesn't happen.
Like,
I don't know,
you,
you would have to,
to get that big,
naturally,
you'd have to,
you couldn't have a job.
You'd have to be eating 30,000 calories a day.
And at the gym,
I mean,
you'd have to be lifting weights literally all day.
and you could probably maintain that amount of mass for a couple of years and
then everything would break.
I mean,
it's just,
it doesn't happen in nature.
And I looked at this dude,
I'm like,
you are going to fucking,
you're going to enforce laws.
Hello Glass House.
What kind of rock bus people for drugs,
motherfucker.
Cause you're on a ton of them,
you know,
I mean that the steroids,
call them drugs or hormones or whatever you want to call them.
And they,
the idea,
and I've talked to guys in martial arts,
let's say,
uh,
you know,
I have to be prepared because the people that I'm running into out on the
street,
you know,
I'm running it to like really bad guys and I want to be enhanced like,
okay,
what is it?
I'm not that familiar with it,
but like
the research,
I understand it fucks with your mind.
Oh,
most definitely younger.
You're obviously,
well,
I mean there's levels of course.
Like everything else.
Like you could smoke a little pot and be fine,
carry on a conversation or you can get so stoned,
you don't remember who you are.
I mean,
you could really get fucked up.
You can get so stone.
You look at a phone,
he like,
what is this?
You know,
you can get pretty fucked up,
right?
Or You could take a little puff and just kicked back.
Joe Talking about cocoa like that.
Coco knows what's up.
He can't tolerate more than any living human being.
Joey Diaz can eat.
He eats it mostly,
you know,
he'll have those pot edibles,
but he'll,
he'll go so deep that you can't even believe he's still alive.
He just goes deep.
But my point being is that I assume that some of these guys,
you could take a small amount of steroids and probably it would help you recover
and in,
but the problem with those guys is they can never get off of it.
Like Joey Diaz has a friend that's been on steroids since 1987 a rod.
Oh No,
I'm sorry.
We were talking about guys.
It's a different guy.
He's a,
his friend from jersey,
that's a bodybuilder that has never gotten off steroids.
He's literally been on steroids since 1987 and he's Joey's age.
You know,
he's like 51 he's fine.
He's healthy.
He's fucking big as a house.
He never stopped lifting.
Never stop doing steroids.
But I mean,
yeah,
but he's a maniac.
I think you could probably take a little bit and it would probably help you
recover and you'll be all right.
But most definitely if you take a lot like this cop that pulled me over,
he had to be on all kinds of shit that's going to fuck with your temper.
I mean,
you essentially become a different thing.
We were kind of discussing this yesterday because there's an epidemic of
steroids in the UFC.
I mean a true epidemic and not just the UFC,
but MMA in general.
There's been some high level guys that have tested positive and other
organizations and uh,
even guys that swore they never took anything and would mock other people who
took performance enhancing drugs and they got popped.
Um,
so there's,
there's a real issue that we're all as the mixed martial arts communities sort
of coming to grips with now.
But as a police officer,
I think being calm and having a sense of,
of peacefulness,
of being able to defuse situations.
Like that was my thing about the Trayvon Martin thing.
Um,
you know,
when everybody was talking about George Zimmerman and the people that were
supporting Zimmerman,
they were like,
you know,
hey,
George Zimmerman had got attacked and Georgia.
I'm like,
okay,
here's the problem with that.
George Zimmerman was a fucking moron,
first of all,
first and foremost,
he wanted to be a cop.
They wouldn't let him be a cop,
which is fucking bad,
which means you gotta be a real moron,
you know,
because I've met some more onto the cops.
You know,
most cops I meet are great folks,
but we all know a few idiots.
It became cops.
This guy was too fucking stupid to be one of those idiots,
you know?
They were like,
you're too dumb.
You can't be a cop.
So they give him this job as this community patrol guy,
right?
And second of all,
he let this kid,
this young kid was kicking his fucking ass.
Young kid got on top of him,
is beating his head off the curb.
Like,
okay,
well how did that happen?
Do you not know how to fight it all?
If you don't know how to fight it all?
How the fuck are you a cop?
Here's the rub that no matter which version of the events you choose to believe,
Trayvon stood his ground first is actually what happened.
So this tree stand,
your ground situation becomes like,
who wins it's becomes is it becomes a stare down at his face off.
It's,
it's a shootout,
you know,
and it's like,
who wins?
Because what happened was he was,
he was being followed by some creepy dude with a gun.
He was a kid coming back from seven 11 with Arizona,
an guys walking back to his dad's house.
But the creepy guy with a gun was a security guard.
Well,
we was a neighborhood watch it.
Like it doesn't have like an half.
No,
no,
no.
Opposite.
Voluntary Yada had punk Chalana whenever he had it was raining and that's why
Trayvon had a Hoodie on.
It was raining so that he doesn't have anything that identifies them as security
officer on the phone with nine one one and they're telling him,
stay in your car,
sir.
Stay in your car.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
And he gets out of the car and he's,
he's stuck.
And this kid was on the phone with the,
Trayvon was on the phone with this girl and he's like,
there's some dude following me.
He's in his car.
He's getting out of his car.
He's like,
and she was worried for him.
She's like,
as it turns out,
he was a creepy dude with a gun who was stalking this.
Katie was walking back to his dad's house with an ice tea and skittles.
I actually wasn't aware that it didn't have an outfit,
which is ridiculous neighborhood
watchman guy.
Nobody elected him or assigned him.
He took it upon himself because it was some robberies in the neighborhood and he
went and stalked and he got jumped because this kid was scared,
so there's no organization whatsoever.
It looks like a community organization,
but I don't know that there's any formal,
I don't think that there,
there was a,
he wasn't a member of any formal organization that I'm aware of.
An eye I was tweeting about this and this was to me was just objective.
These were just objective facts to me and what came into play was one of the
most disturbing things.
I mean,
okay,
I'm all right.
I'm going to tell this story.
I can herself a lot of people so down,
so we have a fan page.
We did this documentary for ESPN called the you,
um,
about the University of Miami football program.
We just did a sequel,
uh,
late last year.
And so we had this fan page that we put on Facebook,
which has about 885,000 or so vans and,
and it's one of the most like kind of largest and most interactive pages for
hurricanes,
football fans.
So every once in a while I kind of troll the page you cause I troll my own page.
Why does he do that as like a sociological experiment?
I don't know.
Like we just like,
we'll just put like,
like Warren Sapp got,
got busted for prostitution.
Yeah.
Uh,
couldn't have happened to a nicer guy.
So stupidest fucking law over the stupidest,
stupidest law.
And to me,
it's just an example of sort of these arcane,
patriarchal,
like women are less,
women can't decide what to do with their bodies.
We decide what they can do with their bodies and,
and what contractual arrangements consenting adults can enter,
can enter into,
but porns legal,
which it should be,
but then it's over there.
There's a camera in the room that changes the entire dynamic.
This was a girl that was hanging around the comedy store way back in the day
that actually said that to one of my friends.
She was a porn star.
And she said,
you know,
he,
he somehow or another gone to this conversation and she said,
you can fuck me as long as you have a camera in the room,
but shoot,
we'll do a private shoot.
And he was like,
what?
It was like,
hold on.
He was like trying to figure it out.
So every time a woman told me that she had a fee,
you know,
she goes,
you pay my fee,
you put a camera in the room and you can fuck me.
And he's like,
says that prostitution,
she goes,
not legally.
And I'm like,
okay.
And then we thought about it like,
yeah,
I guess that isn't prostitution dude.
The resources,
the resources that police departments spend,
you'd been these stings prostitution to create crime that otherwise wouldn't
exist by cops dress up like cookers,
which worst of all is dangerous for them.
Very right.
And second of all,
they're just creating crime that doesn't,
that wouldn't otherwise exist unless this cop trust is a hooker actually passed
laws in certain states that make it legal for cops to have sex with prostitutes
as part of the [inaudible] part of the sting,
which that seems that seems fair,
whole areas.
That seems that seems right.
God damned hilarious.
Why would anybody think that there's,
you know,
there's two legal systems here in this country and make sure that none of these
hoes around this sucking,
so I'm going to go get my
dick sucked.
Just doing sure.
She knows I'm legit.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm pretty sure
by the way,
a contract is offer acceptance and consideration.
I don't know that you actually have to deliver on it in order to say the
contract.
This is an illegal contract that you've entered into.
You're under arrest.
I can't imagine that that's necessary to go into court and say,
it's like,
no,
your honor.
She's really a hooker.
I paid her and we had sex.
Like,
is that really,
is that really necessary and how is that legal?
Well,
my friend got busted in a sting operation in New York and he was flirting with
these girls.
And uh,
one of them said something like,
you want a party or something like that.
And uh,
he's like partying.
Like,
what does that mean?
Like what do you mean,
like sex?
And she goes,
yeah.
And he goes,
um,
is it going to cost me anything?
She goes,
how much do you want to pay me?
He goes,
$10,000.
Like he's just joking around and get the take down in order.
And they fucking around with them.
Like that crane,
he was a drunk guy coming out of a bar,
flirting with some girls that he didn't know where cops and they were
manipulating the language in order to get him to say that,
like he was just being a silly goose.
He,
he's just being a silly guy trying to meet.
He's a comic.
So he's just trying to make these girls laugh like $10,000,
like saying $10,000,
who the fuck is going to pay a street walker?
$10,000 we'll even comes up with that of their first offer.
I mean for $10,000 you can fuck me.
He was a famous porn star for $10,000 offer.
Yeah,
I mean it's maybe been numbing.
If it had been a counter offer,
it would have been more reasonable over $10,000.
If he said,
you know,
500 and she said a million.
And he's like,
Whoa,
hold on.
When you consider these two,
these two women officers,
you consider their backup,
you consider the surveillance,
you consider then when you have to process a John,
when he was in jail for 24 hours,
you have to PR and the,
the manpower involved in processing.
Okay.
What other crime was going on that night?
Uh,
like victim,
victim,
victim less,
but victim,
full victim.
Full farm was occurring.
Oh my God.
Oh,
I totally,
I totally dodged the,
uh,
the trolling my own page bullet.
You,
what should I tell that story?
So we'll keep going with this.
Okay.
I never told this story,
uh,
to any public leadpages.
This,
that you should eat.
It's facebook.com forward slash the you movie.
Okay.
So once in a while when I see troll the page,
I mean we're kind of like the New York post of the,
you have like UN football fan pages were like the tabloid,
you know,
we don't just post the press releases that come out of the athletic department,
we'll post whatever that's kind of like peripherally involved in Miami football
or pop culture surrounding Miami football.
You know,
snoop throws up the U and a music video,
shit like that.
You know.
So
on the day of the Zimmerman verdict,
there was a picture that had been on the Internet for some time from like
Trayvon Martins 11th birthday or something like that,
where his parents are,
who am whomever got him a birthday cake with the IU logo.
He was apparently a hurricane's fan.
I know he's a south Florida kid and so it was it him smiling 11 year old kid and
his universe,
you em,
happy birthday cake.
Great.
So I was just like,
you know what I'm going to do?
I'm not gonna say a word.
I'm going to post this picture to the Facebook page and I can't tell you how
like all social media hell broke loose in that community.
And I would venture to say that you could write papers on the state of America's
race relations based solely on the comments from that,
from that image.
It was one of the most disturbing just exchanges about America and race and
crime that I have just ever seen in my life.
It was so disturbing and I just left it there and let them,
you know,
it was kind of like a war shark and people were writing like private messages
like I'm on,
I'm unfriending or unliking this page.
Um,
why don't you post a picture of Oh,
of course that's not what he looked like when,
you know,
a,
when he was killed and they post like one of those fake pictures of like some
rapper that like people claimed it was Trayvon and like,
like things that were debunked,
you know,
by a scopes and otherwise like,
months or years earlier.
And just like the craziness that ensued and the Ma and I'm like,
hey listen,
you find a picture of a George Zimmerman and a you sweater or whatever.
I'll post that too.
I mean like what do you want?
This is,
it was just,
cause I posted pictures of Barack Obama throwing up the u and then Mitt Romney
was campaigning and he threw up the,
you didn't,
you're like,
well did you throw up to you?
Do you go with this?
Yeah.
You just put your,
well it's more like,
yeah,
it's,
it's like this.
Yeah.
I sort of put a break in it cause there's like era between,
but like you said,
yeah.
But like yeah,
that's,
that's how you,
that's how you sold you.
But essentially,
but let me get to the point here.
Essentially it was white people who were being racist against Trayvon Martin and
were upset that you were posting this image of him with this Uk.
No one was objective looking at the facts of the situation.
They saw a black kid in a hoodie and right away it was thug who gobble was
coming to him.
And it didn't matter that he was a human being.
It didn't matter that he was,
he had smoked pot before.
It's like,
I can't believe the teenage kids,
Teenage Pot's illegal in Florida.
The kid never got into trouble for anything before,
and it's like he,
he got,
he got in a little bit of trouble in school,
which teenage kids do.
He's from a broken home and his mom sent him to spend,
he said,
Mike,
my son needs to spend time with his father.
I'm going to send them up to SPEC.
This was,
these were good people.
This was a good family.
None of it mattered.
A just mattered that he was black and,
and,
and there was people who just literally,
I'm not suggesting that was everybody,
but there were people who just could not get beyond that,
which was just,
it led me to like this whole,
this whole,
Ah,
you know,
the,
I don't know if you remember the,
the closing the closing argument in a time to kill Matthew mcconaughey.
It's like few really think I wants to
fucking,
no,
I seriously doubt that.
But it's like,
it's,
it's this whole monologue where he gives you this fact pattern about this,
this young girl being kidnapped and raped and abused and beaten within an inch
of her life.
And then he says,
now imagine she's white.
Meaning like,
just take the same set of facts and puts your kid there.
You know,
the only reason Zimmerman was following him in the first place,
or scripts on either suspicious or switch the race.
Absolutely Zimmerman be a black guy with a cop complex,
you know?
Well,
well,
my point was initially when we started talking about this is that he's so
socially unskilled that another guy who may be was a good cop or another guy who
was good with people would have seen this young kid walking and said,
how you doing brother?
Everything good tonight?
And like,
yeah man,
what's up?
You know,
what are you doing?
Just getting some skittles.
All right,
we'll take care,
man.
It's great to get dirty.
Fucking hair.
Get,
go,
get dry.
All right,
you too man.
And then we're good.
You know?
I mean,
how many,
how many of those exchanges between two human beings could vary radically
depending on the social skills of the person.
That's quote unquote,
in a position of power.
And that's an issue with what we were talking about earlier with steroids
distorting people's aggression,
distorting people's perception of,
of,
of danger or of their,
their power over a situation or what's,
what's just and what's ethical.
Law enforcement officers are allegedly trained to deescalate.
They should do to office.
Most often.
We're seeing these stories thanks to the Internet of situations where calling
the police turns an otherwise benign situation,
potentially deadly.
And that's a frightening thought,
the,
because even if these are isolated incidents,
the proliferation of them and our exposure to them now thanks to the Internet is
creating an environment where kids are actually feeling like,
I maybe I shouldn't call the police.
Maybe that's not what I should do.
And you shouldn't ever feel that way.
You know,
you shouldn't have that feeling.
But I started to lose a lot of,
like,
when I say friends,
I mean,
you know,
social media,
Fred friends in quotes,
uh,
friends and followers on Twitter.
And I finally just like,
after the verdict,
I was like,
listen,
it's all good.
If you want to follow me for my Trayvon Zimmerman tweets,
if Zimmerman had unfollowed Trayvon,
we wouldn't even be fucking talking about this.
Damn.
He dropped the bomb on them.
Yeah.
Look,
he was a dummy.
He's a dummy who can't fight,
who wanted to be a tough guy and Florida.
This Florida kid getting on top of him.
I'm beating his fucking ass and then he shoots him.
You know,
I just wish someone had taught Trayvon a little better and he could have put
that fucker to sleep before I ever got the gun out.
You know,
you just can't have a person that's so socially unscaled,
which has obviously been proven now
subsequent Jesus fucking Christ,
he pulled a gun out on someone in some sort of a car situation.
He threw a wine bottle and maniac.
Apparently he's a,
he's a con con of a human being.
He's going to kill somebody some day jail while he's probably in jail for a long
time now,
right?
No,
no,
no.
He got picked up on that domestic abuse.
A wrap with his ex girlfriend.
Yeah.
He threw a wine bottle ladder.
She won't cooperate anymore.
She's not pressing he's house.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure he's out now.
You know what,
I'm not a Florida fan of vigilante justice unless it's a guy like that.
And then I'm like,
you know,
that's a day that said that by the way,
that wasn't this
vigilante justice.
But when it comes get free,
[inaudible] is not an endorsement.
People up to fire up torches fucking fine with that cunt sleeping.
It's just,
he's a bad person.
He's a bad person that's already done bad things and you know,
I mean,
it's probably going to continue to do not good.
Maybe.
I mean,
and also he's,
he's become a hero of the Ted Nugent crowd.
You know,
the people that are standing up for the second amendment and he's,
you know,
what he did was he shot an and,
uh,
you know,
unlawful thug or that's fucking retarded,
man.
And I'm a person who supports the right to bear arms.
Just remember the kid did not commit any crimes.
Even jumping.
He was standing his ground.
What is that?
This guy was stalking him with a gun.
There's no set of facts.
Even the waves,
Zimmerman tells it.
There's no set of facts that are set of a version of the story that changes
those facts.
He was stalking a kid who was armed with an Arizona ice tea and skittles walking
back to his dad's house and he killed him.
Neato.
He might've been on pot,
so on the pot.
He was on the pot.
I think the Michael Brown situation is far more confusing because I wish I knew
what really happened.
I wish I knew everybody putting their arms up in the air and doing this.
Hands up.
Don't shoot shit.
I really wished that was proven that that actually did happen.
Maybe perhaps a video.
The way more disturbing story to me was that 12 year old who was shot with a toy
gun and a cops just hold up.
Yeah.
The cops just pull up within two seconds,
unload on him.
All on video,
all on video.
No confusion whatsoever is another situation where the lack of empathy to me and
in the Twitter versus just like staggering cause it's like what was this kid
doing with a toy gun?
I'm like,
I grew up at the park playing with scraps and robbers and war.
What do you want?
I mean,
what?
What are you talking about?
Of course he was in the park.
You can't even address 20 can't even address that.
Those are fools and they're,
they're looking for some reason where this kid,
it was culpable,
you know,
but thinking gains the kid move up right on top of them,
jumped out of the car and open fun.
See,
what's more disturbing to me is,
is the fact that that you have a trend where you have a version of events
perpetuated by the police,
which is usually always the first story you ever read.
It's a press release or the statement from the police.
So it's never innocent until proven guilty.
It's like we charging this guy or we arrested this guy,
this rooms that were arrested for resisting arrest,
that didn't do a Goddamn what they call that,
that's called contempt of cop because there's never a basis to
arrest them in the first place.
So if you're being arrested for resisting arrest,
what was the,
what was the original charge that you were being arrested for?
How can you just,
the vast majority of those cases are dismissed.
And guess what?
Uh,
uh,
Bratton that police commission end YPD wants to escalate,
has gone to the legislature to,
uh,
to elevate contempt.
Go take contempt of cop.
That's what they call that contempt of cop.
He wants to escalate or elevate the charge of resisting arrest from a
misdemeanor to a felony.
Now again,
most of those charges will wind up being dropped as they usually do because
they're completely bogus.
It's contempt of cop.
It's a situation where it's like he didn't listen to me.
Right.
Which is again,
what we were talking about before,
the version,
the difference between deescalation.
You can beat the rap.
You can't beat the ride.
Your boy was in jail for 24 frigging ours might have had to hire an attorney.
Might have had some people get their car impounded,
depending on what town in the prostitution sting sting's.
Those are major revenue generators,
major revenue generators for the criminal justice system,
all the way from law enforcement to tow yards to a asset forfeiture too.
Asset forfeiture,
which is amazing.
What people don't even know about legal.
Take your car.
You could have a very nice car,
like say you have a $50,000 car.
That's the states now they steal your fucking work as a police department.
It's a local,
they get the,
they take the,
keep it sound like they,
they turned it over to anybody.
If they want something,
they could literally go out and take it.
You don't even have to be convicted of a crime just charged or accused.
Right.
And you might never see.
They could take cash from you.
Yes.
Well why?
Why do you have that cash,
sir?
Were you doing something illegal with that cat?
I think you might've been.
So we're going to lock that guilty until proven innocent and then we're going to
use that cash to have fucking parties.
You know what I mean?
They,
they use those,
those,
the,
the funds that they steal.
They didn't have to buy pads and buy cars and boats and the parties and you ran
a similar scam in Los Angeles for a long time with arresting people that were
running medical marijuana dispensaries there.
There's video of this where these fucking kids or college kids,
they're young kids,
they're not doing anything wrong.
They're working in a place where the state law says it's a legal business.
They break in guns strapped,
bulletproof vest,
ATF fucking outfits.
They put guns to people's head,
held this kid on the ground,
stepped on his fucking neck.
I mean there's videos of all the zip tie them the whole deal.
Then they take all their selling legal weed they take,
yes,
they took all their cash,
all of it take all their marijuana,
all of it.
And they say,
we are going to process your case.
And then they do nothing.
They do nothing.
They never prosecute that robbery.
Well,
that's what we used to call.
Yeah,
good.
It is on.
But they take that money and then because these guys don't want to go after that
money,
try to get it back because then the DEA comes out him even harder.
Right.
They use that money to fight to get that money back as much in legal fees as was
stolen in the first place.
It becomes a cancel each other out.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and I saw that you could sue the DEA to get your legal fees paid.
They're not going to pay it.
It's the same problem with did and they also don't care.
Even if they have to pay legal fees,
individual officers are never held liable.
It's not their money.
It's all our money anyway.
Right.
That gets paid when there are wrongful death suits or there's brutality suits or
B,
they don't care.
They're never punished.
The unions completely insulate and protect them and it's not their money.
At worst case scenario,
they get to retire early with a full pension.
The,
it has to be an unbelievably offensive
violation of the law for the cops to be prosecuted.
Prosecuted.
I mean,
it has to be like really outrageous where the,
the state steps in and says,
we've got to do something here or we're going to face a riot.
You know,
look,
the riots they have in Ferguson,
like the riots there,
having all,
all throughout the country about Eric Gardner.
You know what I mean?
I don't think anybody,
I really believe this,
and this is from a life long of experience with police officers.
I don't think anybody is qualified for that job for a long period of time.
I think being a cop is something that you can only do for a very short amount of
time.
Just like being a soldier.
You know that one soldier that went fucking crazy and Iraq and wound up gunning
down all those innocent people and you know,
they pulled this guy aside and like,
well,
this guy had been flagged for PTSD many times and he was saying himself like,
I gotta get Outta here.
And they sent him back over there again and he just went fucking crazy.
I think that the mind can only withstand so much stress and being a cop is a
fucking insanely stressful job and they see horrible things,
which is why I don't,
I'm not a big fan of these blanket statements.
Like you know,
I have friends who are like fuck the police and I'm like no,
stop saying that man.
Cause it's some shit goes down.
You're going to want to call the fucking police.
It's not fuck the police.
Just like when a black person rob somebody,
it's not fucked by a blab.
Absolutely.
It's not man,
it's she's,
these are rash generalizations and they're based on this premise that anybody
could actually do that job.
Correct.
But here in lies the problem wrong.
Herein lies the problem.
The public sector as far as I'm concerned,
should be held to a higher standard of accountability,
not a lower or no account.
I agree with you.
If you are going to have the power and the authority to deprive people of life,
liberty,
and property,
you need to be held to a higher standard.
And a lack of accountability that police officers see happen all over the
country feeds this con this,
this mental idea that you might,
you might very well be right.
That might be a mental deficiency,
might be a form of PTSD that you might actually believe that you're above the
law,
that they don't,
the laws don't apply to you because as you said,
only in the most extreme and extraordinary cases or police officers ever,
ever prosecuted.
Uh,
and I don't think there needs to be a,
or there should be a,
a,
you know,
any kind of referendum or any kind of like,
uh,
I dunno,
like an idea that there's a certain number of police officers need to be proud.
Of course not.
When someone commits a crime out of care,
if they're black,
white or blue.
Okay.
You know,
you need there,
no,
it doesn't need to be a quota.
There just needs to be justice.
Equally applied.
And that's the,
you know,
in Miami,
in the 1980s people,
I mean,
you think if I was here for the Rodney King Riots,
uh,
in Los Angeles,
um,
and so when I think of rat race riots or you know,
you think of Detroit or Watser or Rodney King or,
but Miami was the race riot capital of America.
In the 1980s,
we had no less than three incidents.
All involving police officers.
You have mostly white and Hispanic police officers shooting and killing a,
or in the case of the first one beating to death,
uh,
a black unarmed black men.
And they all resulted in horrific,
uh,
race riots.
Some neighborhoods in Miami have never fully recovered from the 1980 [inaudible]
riots.
You still see empty,
undeveloped entire city blocks that,
that were burned down during those 1980 rights that people have not come back
and reinvested in those,
uh,
in those African American communities.
And we had that in 1980,
83,
uh,
and 89,
when the,
when the eyes of the world were on Miami for the Super Bowl is supposed to be,
oh,
we get all this good publicity.
We're having this,
this worldclass event.
The city was burning because of,
uh,
an officer who had had,
he had first been convicted,
if I'm not mistaken.
And then it was overturned on appeal and he went free.
And,
uh,
w we rioted
what did you think about what happened in New York where those cops got killed
and then they sent out this order?
I don't Dunno what,
how it was,
how it was dictated,
but the,
the idea was they weren't going to arrest anybody
for anything that wasn't necessary.
It was then,
but my take on it was,
that should be how cops always off.
Fantastic.
You should always only arrest people for something that's absolutely necessary.
Yes,
of course.
So what the fuck is this like you for a short period of time went back to
actually being someone who withholds the piece or an enforces the piece or keeps
the peace.
And then from there they went back to being revenue collectors because that's
what the fuck is really going on.
When that kid,
Eric Garner,
that gentlemen,
which a kid,
he's older,
that guy got dragged to the ground and choked,
didn't have any loose cigarettes on him,
wasn't selling thing.
And people are like,
oh that guy had 30 different prior arrests and uh oh he resisted arrest.
That's not resisting arrest.
When you take a fucking innocent person and you violate their rights and you
grabbed him around the neck and throw them to the ground,
that should've never happened in the first place.
And the only reason it happened because of taxes,
that's it.
That guy should have never been arrested.
You know,
you have to remember the river,
you have to remember he's never
been accused of a capital crime.
He wasn't committing a capital crime.
And even if you were,
which is to say that he was facing the death penalty for whatever he was being
accused of.
That's not how we carry out justice in this country.
You don't get choked to death on the street like an animal.
That's not how,
that's not how we roll.
But,
but when you will know that they even tried to claim it wasn't a choke,
which I had a stack of a technicality.
Yeah.
Well,
technically that's what I do for a living.
So he was like,
that's a fucking choke,
you know,
let me do it to you and let me tell you if you could breathe real good,
that's ridiculous.
You grabbing your forum around that guy's neck and squeezing,
that's a fucking choke.
Well,
I think you're right.
I think it exposed,
uh,
policing for profit.
I,
and that's the real issue.
Yeah.
New York City wasn't suddenly a lawless fucking been running Gotham city tat,
I mean,
nothing happened.
Nothing happened.
What,
what happened was that innocent people stopped getting harassed for no reason on
the street over Penny Ante Revenue Generating a law ordinance.
And in that sense,
it's not even the fall of the cops.
The cops were being forced into these situations where they become revenue
collectors.
Like these cops are being forced to go back and start policing as usual because
they have fucking quotas.
And people that say,
oh,
quotas were bullshit.
No,
you have to research it.
They're,
the quotas are fucking real.
They're 100% real,
uh,
an organization,
a great local blog,
uh,
Crespo,
Graham in,
in Miami who does a lot,
he's like obsessed.
We have this chapter one 19,
these public record laws,
we called them sunshine laws where everything's in the sunshine.
It doesn't quite always work that way in Florida,
but a sunny place for shady people and all that.
But he,
he just Didas does public record request nonstop.
And so people start leaking stuff to him before he even request it.
And he got an email that this late,
this like,
uh,
this like third shift is overnight shift in little Haiti neighborhood that the
city of Miami polices arrest quota.
They actually had from,
from like the shift sergeant,
send out an email with quotas that included arrest quotas,
meaning that each officer had to arrest effectuating arrest for what he didn't
specify,
but,
and they had a minimum number of arrests they had to perform during a shift in
six.
Man,
what if you don't encounter anyone committing a crime?
Well,
that's what I,
he said,
what,
what happened in this country?
If the entire country,
if all 350 million people agreed,
okay,
even you fucking hardcore criminals,
no one's going to do anything wrong from month,
just one month
down the opposite of the purse for one month.
No one's going to speed.
No one's going to steal.
No one's gonna do anything wrong.
Just everyone abide by the law even.
I mean,
that's,
that's not outside the realm of possibility.
These things,
these departments would freak the fuck out.
They wouldn't know what to do.
They would have no revenue coming in.
I think about,
you know,
what,
what Hitchin Zola rest in peace.
So He's used to say about,
you know,
the necessity of,
of religion to keep us from becoming savages or B,
we know right from wrong,
we have internal moral compass.
I said earlier,
I'm like,
God,
I wish I could be corrupted so I could make more money and you know,
and,
and take care of my family better,
but like,
but I can't do it.
I think,
you know,
every time I kind of like try to lay off,
I wish I,
you know,
of of just like what's right or wrong.
I get right back on Twitter and I'm like,
this shit's wrong and people need to know about it and like it's the same thing
there.
It's like without the 10 commandments,
would we just start raping and robbing and murdering and I don't think we would
do that as I think we all had,
it goes back to this,
this sense of self worth.
I think we all have by
and large this the sense of self worth and preservation,
which might very well be off the charts,
but I think actually creates,
makes us a little bit more civilized because it's like,
well,
I have too much to lose.
Maybe you know,
I'm not going to just rape rob and murder,
but I think you're right.
I think that's a bad way of addressing it in the first place like this.
I have too much to lose to do that.
No,
you don't want to hurt people.
It feels bad.
It feels bad to insult people.
One of the issues that we have with the Internet is that you know,
you have a real issue with people stalking,
harassing,
being trolling people,
being vicious to people.
Strangers too.
Like people didn't really know because there's no social consequences.
There's no,
you don't,
you don't feel it.
If you're looking at a person and he'd take a person and you show them a picture
of them with 15 diction around,
which by the way,
I'm not really talking about that cause that's usually pretty funny.
Like there's a lot of pictures of me with Dixon,
my mouth.
I've never once tried to take them off the Internet.
I think they're hilarious.
It doesn't bother me.
But for some people it's genuinely upsetting.
Especially women like that.
Find Pictures.
I'm good.
I'm Google tags too,
dude.
Believe me.
Go to my fucking message board.
There's a swarm of them.
I don't have a percent.
Is it got a swarm of Dixon as a gaggle lab?
It's a flock of dicks cauldron.
I Dunno.
I just think,
look,
there's the golden rule of the Internet.
If there's a photo of you and the Internet somewhere,
someone is Photoshop to dick in your mouth.
Just if they haven't,
it's just the boom knew about that photo yet.
I guarantee you by the end of this podcast there will be pictures of you in some
sort of a compromising position with when he said,
if I,
if I didn't have one,
I'd actually be offended.
I feel I feel worse about myself.
I'd be like,
no one's bothered to even Photoshop a dick in my mouth.
You reach a certain amount of photographs of you on the Internet.
It's ultimately inevitable if you're a public person,
you know if you are in oh and have it sounds good.
But Adam fairly edible at this point.
That's been proven,
but I think that you know that,
that that's more fun than anything.
But I think the shit you're talking,
yeah.
Hateful Shit.
Like,
I mean I've seen some really fucking evil harassment that some people have had
to suffer for whatever reason.
It seems to be more women than anything because with women they could use the
rape thing.
Like if a guy tells me he's going to rape me and my,
well,
good luck with that.
That's not going to happen unless you roofie me.
You're not raping me,
Dude.
You know,
no cost.
I mean,
you'd have to,
yeah,
this,
this thing that we can do because of this,
this ability to interact with people with no social consequences.
It's a real issue.
Twitter gangsters,
I called them sad,
lonely Twitter trolls.
Facebook is a little bit better because with Facebook you can click on the
person's profile and you see,
oh,
this is like something like Jones from Baba blustery or some fucking day.
Yeah,
exactly.
Stupid handle and yeah,
I mean that does become a real issue with social interaction,
but I think it's a temporary hiccup.
I really do.
I think that this we're in as a stage of,
I'm also an adolescent stage of interactivity where what we're experiencing now
is,
is just,
it's a,
it's a weird like bridge between total connectivity.
I,
the complete absence of any form of privacy is on the way and it might be a
hundred years from now.
It might be 30 it might be in our lifetime,
it may be a couple months from now.
Somebody might come up with something and they'll say,
look,
this is going,
this one thing that we're going to implement is going to be unbelievable as far
as exchanging information.
As far as our knowledge base,
the actual Iq of human beings is going to double within weeks.
We're going to change the world,
but no more privacy.
I mean we're in like the learning curve.
It's going to happen.
We are essentially,
we were driving around and model A's,
but one day someone's going to invent a fucking nine 11 gt three and you know,
if you went back and took time when Henry Ford's driving around his stupid
fucking shitty car,
you know Brian and you pulled up beside him in a Mustang,
Shelby gt 500 and go check this shit out.
I'm from the future.
Oh boy.
He'd be like,
what the fuck is that dude?
I'm 660 waiting on the hoverboard.
I'm still waiting on the hoverboard.
But if you have like a hover board is just you just floating,
what's the big deal?
It's just not touching anything.
Whoa.
It's so crazy.
We have jets that go faster than the speed of sound.
I mean,
that's the hoverboards dog shit.
Ooh.
Can Float so it can a plain stupid.
I just don't get how much the world has changed.
We're,
we're,
we're working at a doc about,
uh,
about nine 11 right now.
And,
and it's,
it's like,
it's been like 14 years,
which is incredible because it seems like such a modern history of Virginia is
of course a modern historical event.
But it seems like just yesterday and when you consider how much the world has
changed,
particularly tech technologically,
there was no Twitter,
no Instagram.
There was no,
you know,
there was,
uh,
there was barely youtube at that point,
you know?
Uh,
so I think youtube actually know him.
You know,
it wasn't,
no.
Youtube was like Chuck [inaudible] 2003 or 2004.
There was like Napster and 99.
But now you've just think of how far we've come.
I think you're right.
This is just the infancy of of era.
Yeah.
And I think um,
like what you're talking about on your website where all these people were
getting upset and you know the,
the Trayvon Martin thing and people are interacting and his racism and all this,
all that stuff I think is a byproduct of this.
The monkey DNA that we still carry around in our bodies.
And I think we're on our way to transcending that and some very strange way
where it's not going to matter what part of the world you're from.
It's not going to matter.
It's all that.
One of the things we've seen like these people getting yup.
Cause people getting married in Alabama,
he's,
you know the,
the way though the world is changing that I believe is 100% because of the
Internet.
I believe that wholeheartedly.
And that's one of the things that encourages me.
And I feel like this trend,
like today,
like no one could try to bring back slavery today,
but in 1870 1865,
1860,
these were real,
these are real arguments where people were saying we should be able to keep
slaves.
That's a fucking blink of an eye,
man.
That is not that long ago.
You're talking about 150 years at,
that ain't shit.
That's not shit historically.
I mean,
that's so cool.
So recent and more so now than ever before.
More so within the last few years than ever before.
And you know,
you've seen ridiculous things.
I would like the social justice warriors,
these really weird white people that are trying so hard to get black people,
to love them,
that they just go out of their way to just be outrageously progressive to the
point where they're actually prejudice against other white people.
They're like,
they go so far left to become right.
You know,
I mean,
I've seen some ridiculous shit where I saw this one guy who was quoting about
Osama bin Ladin saying that,
um,
I will never a celebrate someone's death.
Uh,
you know,
even if they were a horrible person,
and then the same guy quoted about Christopher Hitchens,
you know,
good riddance.
He was a misogynist and a warmonger like,
okay,
fuck head.
He's like,
I can't,
can't have it both ways,
but what he is,
is the Uber version of the social justice warrior,
the unfuckable white dude trying so hard to get women and black people to love
him because he just is completely insubstantial in any real form in our,
and our,
the,
the normal context of our culture.
I find the more,
you know,
the thinking about race so much,
it's kind of racist.
So like the more kind of progressive you get about these issues,
the more you're thinking about sensitivity and the more,
I think that's an overcorrection to say the least.
You know,
I w we,
um,
like black Annie Black Annie,
they're doing black uncle buck.
Did you know that?
I just wanted to bang my head.
They don't have to do that.
That,
that trend that like what is that?
Like the late nineties,
early Zeros when like hip hop was peaking,
they did a black,
there was the black honeymooners.
I never,
there was a black airplane with soap sold.
So that trend is like coming back around again.
Like we have to do that,
we have to do the black version of like all of these like pop culture they
touched down.
So this is,
it's demeaning,
it's demeaning to black people to do that.
And first of all,
soul plane.
I know the guy who created it,
White Guy Nitel,
that opportunist kind of a con.
It's just what's going on is people are taking advantage of this opportunity to
like to,
to capitalize on a market.
Cultural,
ultra vultures culture vultures.
Great way of looking at it.
Last year,
early last year,
we did a mini series for VH ones,
rock docs series.
I think it might've been their,
one of their last rock docs ever,
um,
called the tanning of America at one nation under hip hop.
And so it panic the tanning of America,
one nation under hip hop,
as long as there's no black face vogue.
And it was written,
it was a book called the Tanning America written by a guy named Steve Stout who
was,
uh,
major duty guy in the record business and is now a big in the Mar,
our marketing and advertising world.
And His thesis was that hip hop culture led to the election of the first black
president.
The idea that a generation of Americans that grew up immersed with the music,
the fashion,
how it infiltrated the Wall Street Madison Avenue in the consumer goods,
uh,
a sector.
And we just grew up immersed in this culture.
Uh,
it tanned the mental complexion of Americans and made it okay or even cool to
vote for,
uh,
the first black president.
And so we had four hours to kind of prove this,
this thesis.
And we go to Sundance last year,
um,
I think it was actually the venue was called the black house.
Um,
and it was an event that sort of celebrated the African American cinema and
culture that was going on at Sundance.
And so we're going to do like this panel discussion because the movie wasn't
done yet and we're going there.
And someone said to me for the first time,
you've been working on this project for almost two years or a year and a half.
like particularly,
I guess they were concerned about that environment,
uh,
the black,
the black house,
which turned out to be a fantastic experience.
But they said,
well,
what if somebody says like,
why are you guys doing it?
You know,
you to like white Jewish dudes from,
from Miami.
Why,
why,
why are you guys doing this documentary?
And I was like,
and the thought had never crossed my mind.
Like,
I didn't even think about that.
why would this think about great story,
great idea,
great concept,
a challenge to kind of prove that,
which is what you do,
you cover historically.
And I never thought.
And then,
and then I sort of,
and then I started thinking about it and I'm like,
well,
why am I even thinking about this?
Like,
and,
and like someone put it in Yoga and my head with it and,
and white privilege and white privilege.
And then I started getting white guilt about it.
White male privilege.
She's like,
Oh shit,
have white guilt.
And I started feeling like,
well wait,
is it white male privilege that I never thought about this before?
Course I was like,
Oh shit.
Course it is shame.
I know.
Shame on you.
I was really in my head about this hunks upon you.
And I'm like,
and what if somebody else brings it up like publicly or asks me about it or what
the hell am I going to say or do rocks?
And I,
and I,
and I thought about it,
I thought about it for literally,
that entire thing happened in like a millisecond.
And then I'm like,
well,
first of all,
uh,
we are that generation.
I thought about my childhood in living color was my SNL.
Arcenio Cineo was my Johnny Carson.
I grew up a white,
white Jewish kid.
I watched two to seven.
I watch the Cosby show.
A different world.
Amen.
You remember the show?
Am I watching?
Amen.
Was Amen.
What Deacon for you?
Remember that it took place at like a black church with,
um,
with,
what's his name?
George Jefferson was like,
it was like,
it was,
it was a great show.
But what the hell am I watching it for?
But I loved it.
I didn't think about,
I looked at Sanford and son CSeries fucking shows time.
Norman Lear,
a little white Jewish guy like me.
It was responsible for,
for the first all black sitcoms on television,
a Sanford and son,
the Jeffersons,
good times.
Um,
all in the family,
which really brought the discussion of race to tell it to mainstream television
in the way standup comics were doing it,
obviously well before that,
but,
but said,
we're going to go on network television and have serious conversations about
politics and race and poverty in this country.
White Jewish guy.
And then you'll look at Russell Russell Simmons teams up with Rick Rubin,
a white Jewish guy.
Uh,
at Nyu.
Um,
you look at all,
you know,
in all of these sort of relationships that helped,
uh,
you know,
we interviewed Brett Ratner,
White Jewish kid from Miami beach who was loved hip hop because hip hop wasn't,
it was,
it wasn't just urban music,
it was youth culture,
music.
And that's why capture the generation of,
you know,
kids who didn't want to listen to what their parents were listening to,
and it wasn't rock and roll anymore.
It became hip hopper or rap music at the time.
And the second thing was Steve Stout,
to his credit,
when we walked in the room to meet with him,
he didn't know we were white.
He knew we did cocaine cowboys.
He knew we did the you,
he knew the work and he respected and liked the work.
So he's like,
oh,
I want to work with those guys who did this shit that I like and respect.
It was like,
oh wait,
they're white.
So to his credit,
he never thought about it either.
So it's like,
why should I start thinking about it?
I'm dealing with the same thing right now with dog fight.
That's what I'm dealing with.
To these folks.
Explain,
uh,
your,
your new project first.
I got to spell it.
Yeah.
It's Ea Wg,
Michael Vick,
dog fight.
It's not like a pit bulls.
It's done.
It's not,
it's it's dog fight.
Well,
the underground culture in Miami,
there's a been a like a street fighting culture.
Well this was the subculture that,
that real look,
I'd say Kimbo slice was kind of responsible for it anymore.
He became the,
uh,
you know,
the role model for a new generation of young people in Miami to literally try to
fight their way to a better life.
And there's this neighborhood,
which is right,
right where Kimbo came from and would fight in the backyards called West Brine.
So this is 22 miles southwest of South beach.
So when you think Miami,
you,
most people default,
like I said,
but you know,
to ocean drive,
this is 22 miles southwest of that.
This is an area that I call a suburban ghetto.
And I say that because when you think of ghetto or an urban neighborhood,
you think of,
um,
you think of vertical,
you know,
people stacked in projects,
now,
you know,
on top of each other,
next to each other.
But purline as these very modest houses in like a,
on a,
on a pretty reasonably sized lot.
So you have a little house and you'll have a,
a nice size yard.
And so Dada,
$5,000 a year.
Harris,
he's this guy who actually,
there's a video of him,
a youtube video that we use in the movie of him benching in his mom's yard there
and pride,
650 pounds.
He benches,
um,
and he's benching,
but he's bench pressing and team Kimbo comes rolling by and sees this guy,
this beast.
And he's like,
I'm to fight ray Mercer in Atlantic city.
Why don't you roll with us?
So for a year,
dot.
I's on the fucking jet,
you know,
going around the world with,
with,
with team Kimbo.
Kimbo was very slick in that fight with Ray Mercer who is very smart,
caught him in a fucking good team.
He's like,
listen bitch,
I learned some new shit.
I ain't standing up with you.
A Olympic gold medalist world heavyweight boxing champion.
Fuck you.
I'm going to fucking choke your neck and Kimbo like when he did that,
like Ray Mercer was pissed off.
You saw the ray Mercer fight with Tim Sylvia.
Just see that finally God Damn Ray Mercer,
he hit Tim Sylvia with a punch to it.
Probably took a year and a half off his life.
I mean one punch,
he KOD him.
It's terrible.
He k owed him so viciously with this one punch.
I mean he was one within the first 1520 seconds of the fight cause hit him flush
on the Chin and knocked him dead.
So you're seeing that in a legal sanction environment where they were,
the fighters had had checkups,
they were waiting and there's a doctorate ambulance.
Why these are like on Indian reservations that stuff.
Well imagine it in a fucking backyard.
Oh Dude,
I've seen a law.
He Seen Alex because Sarah's who fights for the UFC right now.
He got his start doing that shit.
So did Jorge Mas Dahl,
who's a high level fighter in the UFC mosfet doll fought a lot of those fights.
Well that,
that's like,
to me like the origin story,
that's the goal for these guys.
You have a neighborhood that is,
um,
you know,
over a third black,
uh,
that's majority,
of the,
of the community is bill,
you know,
below the poverty level.
Um,
what employment is like a third higher than the national average.
And you basically have a community with very little hope and very little
opportunity.
You know,
you've criminalized a vast majority of the male population,
so they're not,
they can't get work and they think that their best hope is to fight in these
illegal unsanctioned bare knuckle backyard brawls,
upload the footage to youtube and hopefully get discovered by a professional and
then a promoter or trainer and,
and try to go pro.
Look at Kimbo Kimbo slice has made millions of dollars.
The guy that he's done that Horatio Alger story that,
that,
that they aspire to be and he recently got signed for Bellator.
He's going to fight again until this Kimbo.
Um,
it's a good question.
I would say he's probably in his forties now.
You know,
uh,
when he fought for the ultimate fighter,
I think he was like in his late thirties,
let's say Kimbo slice data.
So they blew up team Kimbo blew up a fighter named level level Martinez 31 41.
Wow.
Um,
I'm thinking that's old in the way in the world and the average age of heavy
weights tend to age uh,
better.
Um,
but uh,
he fought at two oh five,
I believe in the UFC.
I think there's something going on with heavyweights where your body takes
longer to learn how to move all that mass.
If I had a look at it that way,
lighter weight fighters also rely much more on speed and reflexes.
I think as you get larger,
you tend to rely more on skills and more on just sort of an understanding of
what your body can and can't do.
They can't have smaller gas tanks is undeniably,
there's no way a heavyweight,
unless you Cain Velasquez who's a really a fucking freak of nature,
can fight at the same sort of a pace that a lighter weight guy can.
So the thing that UFC heavyweight champion,
Cain Velasquez,
one of the most unique athletes I've ever seen,
he's lends itself to longevity.
I mean,
you just sorta like go at him in his case,
no,
because he's all fucked up can't,
I mean Kane who was an amazing fighter and one of the,
I think he might is a good argument.
He might be the best heavyweight of all time,
but he's body keeps breaking.
He keeps blowing out knees and shoulders.
He's,
because he's so mentally tough and he's so driven and focused and so intense and
dedicated that he pushes through injuries and you can't fucking do that.
You know,
when you push through injuries,
what happens is they just break further.
You know?
I mean,
you can't push through a knee injury.
You what you're doing is,
yeah,
you got to get surgery or are you got to heal?
You've got to figure out a way to recuperate the scenario or,
or,
or alter your training so that you,
you know,
this doesn't happen in the future,
but they're all just so fucking tough man.
Which is what made them great wrestlers in the first place and would allow them
to transition into MMA.
But Cain has this insane gas tank where he just doesn't get fucking tired.
He just overwhelms guys because he's just,
he's got so much fucking cardio and a lot of it is probably natural,
like his,
just his body.
It's different.
People have different like natural vo two Max is,
it's just,
it's one of those things like some people have more fast twitch,
muscle fiber.
Some people have thicker bones,
some people have more.
They can just,
especially for some reason it seems like Mexicans in particular have very good
cardio.
It's really common,
you know that,
I mean it could conceivably be that a lot of Mexican folks come from really
hardworking environments and they've been forced to work like labor jobs.
Like a lot of them,
especially second third generation whose parents had an arduous trek to get over
here from Mexico.
You know,
it could be mental,
it could be just more mentally tough or it could be some physiological aspect.
But my point is that like,
he's a rarity in that his gas tank is just insane.
Most heavyweights,
as they get older,
they kind of learn how to pace themselves better.
They learn their skills,
they learn how to be more efficient with their movement.
Like Vladimir Klitschko,
who is just unstoppable as the heavyweight champion in boxing,
I believe.
I want to say he's 39 years old,
which is it mean he's coming into his own now.
I mean,
when he was younger,
he went to a streak where he got stopped,
I think two fights in a row.
He got Kod and you know,
wasn't,
wasn't looking good for him.
And now he's like,
you know,
all these years later,
he's like unstoppable.
Yeah.
He's,
um,
he's 38 right now and he's,
you know,
he hasn't lost like 10 fucking years.
I'm kind of fascinated by this because I'm just getting into it now.
I spent almost two years following this and several years in post trying to find
a way to get done.
Release is almost done.
We're scoring it now.
It's coming out March 12th.
And will it be in the film a dog-fi.com
da wg-fight.com or if he,
if that's tough to remember.
Cocaine cowboys.com we'll,
we'll,
we'll eventually,
we'll eventually get you there.
You'll,
you can click through.
Yeah.
But um,
uh,
we,
it's going to be online.
It's going to be online.
You're gonna be able to get it there at the site.
Like what will it be on Netflix will be eventually.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
TV.
Oh,
absolutely.
Eventually,
eventually everywhere.
I'm hoping to eventually get it on showtime.
We've had,
we've had a great run with the cocaine cowboys movies and some of our men are
their docs on showtime.
So good cooking cowboys there.
The critic at the Miami Herald saw a rough cut cause we're [inaudible] that
shit.
No,
no.
They didn't know the movie critic who's a great guy by the way.
Renee Rodriguez.
I love her name.
He saw a rough cut.
Renee,
he saw a rough cut and he said it's our best movie dog fight.
Whoa.
And strong words.
Cocaine cowboys one was amazing cocaine cowboys to might've even been better.
Really might've been better said.
No one ever said me.
Grizelda God damn,
that bitch is terrible.
Whenever I hear about people like doing shit for money or for a paycheck,
I was just like,
listen,
I did cocaine cowboys to hustling with the godmother.
I directed a movie called cocaine cowboys to hustling.
Not even hustling,
hustling with an apostrophe at the end of it with the God that's in my
filmography.
Thank you.
You're very kind.
You're not kind.
I fucking do.
You do not like the second one as much as the first one.
I don't really.
Yeah,
I mean,
if I'm ranking for,
you know,
I always say movies,
movies are like kids.
You,
when people say,
do you have a favorite?
Yeah,
but I'm not going to tell you.
You know,
like that's the same thing with kids.
It's like every parent,
I don't care,
give a shit what they say.
I love them all equally.
No you don't because some kids are just assholes.
You can't possibly,
you know,
and,
and some of them are screw ups in life and my children,
no,
I got it.
Yeah.
You can kind of love them all equally because I think when kids like them all
equally,
it's Kinda of,
there's a part of it that's your fault.
That's the thing that you feel guilty,
you're saying guilds compensates for,
for the [inaudible],
for the lighter raises the love because you feel that they need more love
because you screwed them up.
You're responsible for their being dog.
That killed one of my other dogs.
I love the dog that she killed,
but I loved her just as much and it was very sad.
I mean,
obviously I should have loved the dog that got killed more cause she wasn't a
cunt.
She wasn't an asshole.
That was,
you know,
out there killing the other dogs.
But this,
this dog was a sweetie and I picked her up at the pound and she lived at the
pound.
She was in one of those no kill shelters for like eight months.
And when I was young,
man,
I had a real problem in that.
Um,
it's hard to talk about I guess,
um,
where I felt like,
I felt I always had this,
uh,
this need to help strays.
And I think I had this need to help strays because I felt like a stray and when
I would see a a dog in a pound or a clicker,
I bought a cat from a fucking pet store cause it hissed at me,
you know,
cause I felt his poor fucking cat like scared of me.
You don't have to scared of me.
I love you.
And uh,
I felt that way about this dog,
this poor Dar.
I used to call it a squeaky cause uh,
when I picked her up,
she couldn't even talk.
She couldn't bark because she had barked so much,
so often in this pound that have her voice was gone.
So when she was barking in the pound,
she'd be like,
Yeah
Huh.
It was like this squeaky noise.
And I was like,
what the fuck is wrong with her voice?
And I realized,
Oh my God,
she's barking all day and she doesn't have a voice anymore.
And then when I took her home and took care of her,
she eventually got her voice back and she barked like a normal dog.
But that dog fucking loved people.
She loved people.
She was so happy to be out of that shit.
But she didn't like other dogs.
Cause if other dogs came near her,
she felt like it was a competition for love.
Like if you came near another dog,
that other dog was going to get that love.
So she would get upset at that dog for stealing love from her and she would try
to attack it.
So I loved her to equally,
even though she was an idiot,
you know,
but it wasn't her fault that she was an idiot.
You know,
I,
it would,
I would,
uh,
I realized from then on,
I will never get a dog that's not a puppy that you got to raise him from the
time they're puppies because then you don't have any,
they don't have any phobias or weirdness and you get a chance to raise them
around people and raised them around other dogs and socialize them.
And it's an important aspect of humans.
Just like it's an important aspect of any other animal that's in our culture.
So,
um,
you know,
I,
you can love your fucking shitty kids just as much as you love your good kid.
It's just because it's partly your fault that they're shitty.
I don't know about though.
You eat your party,
it's your fault for being them into the world.
Some people just won't stop.
I don't believe that.
I believe.
No,
I don't think so.
I think,
um,
I think it's how they're,
some people require more attention,
uh,
on,
I don't think people are born assholes.
There's nature versus nurture.
But I think that because there are people who endure in what I would consider.
Many other people consider intolerable stress and abuse and don't become
psychotic assholes.
And then there are people who are born or raised in the most loving and
nurturing,
uh,
and,
and permit and permissive and enabling environments and become
deranged lunatic.
So how do you account for now by that?
I think those people that become deranged lunatics,
they probably didn't get the attention that it deserved or they probably didn't
get the look.
Raising a human being is not as simple as just sending the kids to school and
talk him into bed at night.
You,
you're,
you're training them,
you're communicating with them,
you're imparting love and you're in part they,
they learn by imitating their atmosphere.
They learned by imitating their environment or they learned because they get
ignored and they figure shit out on their own.
Some do
learn different ways and people absorb the lessons they learn in different ways.
It's like you were talking about the sort of the chemical makeup of a fighter
and how different bones and different bodies respond differently to different
stimulus and depending on your size and your shape and,
and,
and your training and your steroids or whatever.
I think that that happened.
That's,
that's true of a becoming.
You're born with a certain chemical balance and I'm not saying that can't shift
or change with time,
but I think there are certain inclinations we are
born with good or bad that cannot be rectified by a proper or upbringing born
with like right out of the box right out of the box.
I don't buy that at all.
You're gay,
you're crazy.
You're black,
you're white world and crazy and black all in one sentence.
How dare you.
No wonder why people are so upset at you.
It's just those were mutually exclusive uh,
examples and I just,
but I think that there are,
there are unquestionably characteristics that you cannot raise or beat or love
out of somebody that they are just ingrained in them.
I think you should probably have kids before you say that.
I really do.
I think he's probably have kids and raise them from the time they're babies and
see the developmental process.
Cause it's a lot of you,
what you're doing right now is just speculating and me,
I've raised three kids.
I've been there,
I've,
I've seen the process of good and bad,
the corrective process.
And I've been very lucky that my kids don't have develop developmental issues or
mental issues,
and some kids are certainly born with that,
but I think to a large extent,
children imitate their environment and there's certainly a lot of deterministic
factors.
There's a lot of genetic factors is a lot of like in intangible variables that
are difficult to,
there's going to be kids that are more selfish.
She's going to be kids that are more angry.
There's going to be kids that are more outgoing.
There's going to be kids that are more gregarious,
but you're always gonna have that regardless if you're going to have shitty
people though shitty people come from abuse.
Almost always.
Almost always when you have a really terrible person,
that terrible person is not treated with love.
Almost universally,
I just don't buy that unless you have some like real issue,
like a real brain issue,
right?
Where there's like some part of the mind,
it develops decay or there's a tumor,
there's an injury,
there's something where there's a,
there's a disconnect.
[inaudible] very critical processes.
Unless that's the case,
like you don't,
you don't make a monster.
I believe.
I said,
I don't think that's true.
I think,
I think you can choose to be a good person or a bad person.
I think there are some people that cannot choose that are based on that.
Based on who.
I mean example,
you're seeing it's a very bold statement.
I don't think it's that.
I don't,
I don't think they're very bold saying that some people are fucked from birth.
That's what you're saying.
I'm not talking about this spiritual way.
I,
I'm,
I'm talking about it and very much saying spiritual were saying the way they
behaved.
Like you,
you're saying that some people,
no matter what you do,
no matter what,
how much effort you put in,
how much love you give these kids and how much IX you expose them to different
environments.
You give them different tasks and different learning opportunities.
There's still going to be shitheads.
Yes.
That's,
that's,
that's such a bold statement that says,
but why would you say that?
That's bay.
You have no data.
It's not based on anything.
Oh,
yeah,
but,
but it's also a question about how you define,
but it is there,
there's isolated cases of that.
Every week there's isolate.
It's Affluenza.
Affluenza is like isolated cases.
You should have those isolated cases in your mind.
If you're saying some siting right now I'm citing the Atla the affluenza cases
for example.
Oh,
that's this gift.
Flu.
No,
no,
not influenza.
Affluenza.
Oh,
athletics.
It's this new made up thing that say these kids are shitheads because they've
been given,
they've been given everything in life.
So now they're assholes as,
and you would argue and,
and,
and the ferry was there most likely ignored because they have money doesn't mean
they have love and doesn't mean they have learning experiences.
Doesn't mean someone has been nurturing them or guiding them or mentoring them.
Those are the issues that people have.
It's not money.
What I'm saying,
it's also possible that they have mental defects.
That's all I'm really talking about,
which is what you've already said.
Which that is that.
Sure.
People who have,
who are wired is what I'm saying to,
to,
to uh,
propensities to violence to be shot.
It's very possible that they do.
However,
most likely if they become costs is because someone did a shitty job of raising
them.
That includes this Affluenza,
which is a very new term,
which is why I fucked me up because it's a horrible thing.
It shouldn't be a thing.
Well,
they've been using this to exonerate people.
It's crazy,
bizarre world though where we are and you're going to,
you're going to get on me about this too because I don't have kids,
but his,
this world where everybody's looking for an answer for why their kid's an
asshole,
for why their kids acting out for why their kid is too sensitive for why they're
getting and everybody needs a diagnosis.
Everybody in orange and or a drug that can help fix them.
Everybody needs to know like,
oh,
I'm not fucking up.
My kid actually has some invented.
Likely by the time you have one of those issues,
you've already fucked her care.
That's what's going on.
Children or animals.
Okay.
Just like a person on a grown adult.
It's a puppy animal.
It's an animal and animals react to their environment.
Have you ever had a feral cat?
No.
I've had feral cats and my friend Lanie,
her and her boyfriend found these fucking cats underneath the house and the the,
the,
this cat had given birth these cats and she was given away kittens and I,
again,
I have to take in stray.
So I took this fucking stray inn and this crazy fucking cat was in my house.
And learning from feral cats,
you realize like,
oh,
okay,
like this cat is already fucked.
Like by the time I got to it,
it was x amount of months old or whatever it was.
There was no fixing this fucking thing.
It was already fucked.
And that is the case with human beings.
You develop a certain amount of pathways in your,
your mind,
in your intellect,
in the way you comprehend the world and the way you,
you,
you interact with your environment.
That's based upon the dangers that you've been exposed to based upon the input
that you've had.
And once those pathways are defined in a very violent negative way or whether
you've been ignored or whether you've been spoiled to the point where you could
scream at the help and yell at the housekeepers and everybody bows down in front
of you because you're a Rockefeller or so,
he said something along those lines,
the affluenza aspect of it.
When you get to a certain point,
those pathways are so established in the mind that it's insanely difficult to
change that.
So when you're coming along you're saying like,
Hey,
you know,
I need a pill to fix my kid.
No,
you didn't pay attention to them enough.
Like a child needs constant attention.
Babies need to have a mother around them all the time.
A father around them all the time,
they need input.
They need to try to develop an understanding of their world.
And a lot of people don't do that.
They pass their kid off to the fucking nanny.
They don't pay attention to it when it cries in the crib and they,
they wonder why their kid gets fucked up when they're working 17 hours a day and
they never see the kid and I'm like,
I don't have any fucking time to deal with this kid.
Let's put him on Prozac.
Well,
how do you,
what happened?
How do you then explain to people who overcome adversity,
who come from horrific life?
Just because you can make something of themselves because you can because it can
be done.
Doesn't mean everyone's going to do it.
Not everyone's going to finish a fucking marathon just because people start
running.
Some people run a hundred miles,
they do that ultra marathon.
Some people get five miles in there like,
I can't fucking do this.
And for whatever reason they decided to take a nap.
They decided to sit on the side of the highway and stop.
Some people,
they decide,
you know what,
my mom was a prostitute,
my dad was a junkie and I am not going to be like that.
I'm going to learn it and I'm never going to have a drink.
I have a friend who's a great guy and his grandmother used to lock him in his
fucking room and lock the door and leave him there for the weekend so she could
get drunk.
His mom was never there,
his parents were never there and he,
this fucking guy to this day won't touch alcohol and not to say I'm not against
whole.
Right.
And is terrified about food.
Like he,
oh he will,
he will not throw food away.
Like when he goes to a restaurant and he gets scrapped.
I mean it can be a tiny portion.
That guy will take that to go with him.
He will not waste food is because when he was a kid he was exposed to this
horrible situation.
But other people could have been exposed to that and become a serial killer.
Other people can mix both supposed to the same situation and design because the
pre predisposed to being good or bad people.
That's exactly.
No,
it's not a predisposed.
He made choices and it became a fighter.
And one of the things about martial arts gave him a sense of self worth and
character.
But you can't say that it's,
he's predisposed to be a good person or someone else would be predisposed to be
a bad person.
A lot of it is these subtle variables that happen when you're interacting with
your environment.
I think some of those subtle variables that are chemical,
they are in the brain.
They,
they,
they do,
they do exist in end.
It's possible,
but it's also you should know what you're talking about when you're saying these
kinds of things.
Like you're,
you're stating them as facts and I think there's a real issue with that when you
don't have any data.
I'm seeing them as opinions.
But you're not seeing here is you're saying when you're saying that some people
are,
fuck I'm saying,
I believe I'm saying that people,
but you're arguing it so strongly like you,
you have this in your mind as a rigid idea.
I mean there's definitely possibilities as far as mental deficiencies.
I mean,
look,
some people are born blind,
you know,
some people are born,
they don't have any hands.
So there's,
there's a lot of issues with human beings.
We don't come out perfect.
But to say that some people could do a great job and the kid's just gonna be a
monster anyway,
most likely not.
Most likely.
What you're seeing is people that do not want to take responsibility for the
fact that they did a shitty job of developing a human being.
That might be by and large shoe,
but you do have,
but,
uh,
schizophrenia is,
is a legitimate mental defect.
I can't believe,
I don't believe we're talking about race,
but that's what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about disposition to Ken about leukemia or schizophrenia.
You're talking about people being assholes.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not.
But that's what you were saying.
If you grow up to be a truly disturbed individual,
there are,
there's not always an opportunity to change that or to reverse that trend
regardless of how well your broad opera,
how loving Affluenza as an example of that.
That's not schizophrenia.
That's a people that are ignored their fucking kids.
Oh No,
absolutely.
What I'm saying but I'm saying is is is is that there are people who have a
predisposition towards certain behavior and there are people who may or may not
be be raised.
Right.
I think we're confusing the two issues.
I think ultimately you might actually be saying the same thing in one way or
another,
but I'm saying I'm talking about legitimate defects in individuals,
legitimate defects and individuals call them,
call them mutations,
called them what you will most certainly there are legitimate defects in certain
individuals most certainly but I think that a lot of what we're dealing with as
a culture as a community is if you look at people in indigenous cultures,
they're constantly around their children,
they spend all this time with their children and you,
you see far less instances of mental issues.
You see far less mental diseases,
you say far less issues of depression.
And there's this sort of existential angst that we exhibit almost like more
frequently than not in our culture.
And I think a lot of that has to do with the developmental process of a child is
not just misunderstood,
but is ignored and is,
is treated in a way where it's,
it's a very irresponsible,
the way a lot of people raised children.
Like I have friends,
I'm still really nice.
I have two friends that are very,
they're very nice folks and they both work insanely difficult jobs where they're
gone all day long and their kids are starting to be fucked up.
And we've been friends with them for a long time.
So I've known the kids since they were little.
They've got a kid.
I mean,
I can't be too specific about it or I'll be,
but their son,
it's fucked up man.
And they're smart,
but they're,
they don't have the time and they're not around the kid all the time.
And the kids terrified and he fucking screens in the middle of the night all the
time.
They're never home.
They're,
they're fucking,
they're,
they have nannies to take care of them.
And the kids are really confused and these people have long hours,
they work long hours and I don't see that changing.
And I see their kids coming out of this in a very fucked up way and I'm watching
it happen from the beginning to,
to where they are now to the point where me,
me and my family were kind of avoiding them.
Now we don't want to hang out with them because their kids are starting to be
disturbed.
They started the,
they're,
they're acting aggressive towards other kids and some sort of a weird way.
Um,
you there,
there need to be around their parents.
It's like,
it's,
it's not,
it's not normal.
It's like this like,
like they're drowning,
you know,
like they need air and their parents are air.
It's like they cling to them,
they hold onto them,
they're scared of everything.
And what it is is these kids are not being nurtured correctly because it's not
natural in the wild as a human being,
as an organism.
It's not natural to be away from your,
your parents for 16 hours of every day.
It's not,
it's not natural to see your parents just as you go to bed and as you wake up,
that's fucking crazy.
But that is the norm for a lot of these people that want their cake and they
want to eat it too.
They want to have a career and also have children.
You know,
I know a woman who is a fucking huge executive at a major company and this crazy
lady has three kids and they're all nuts.
They're fucking kids are nuts.
You know why?
Cause Mommy barely exists.
Mommy barely,
ma'am,
mommy exists in their life for 10 minutes a day.
That's nuts,
man.
That's nuts for a three year old and they don't know what mommy is.
They don't,
they're not around her.
You're supposed to be around her hours and hours.
I supposed to be cuddled and nurtured and you play with them and you teach them
about life.
You teach them how to talk and how to count,
you know?
And then I have another friend and his wife doesn't work at all.
And the kid is three,
it can already count to a thousand and already knows how to spell his name is
spelled words because why?
Because the mom's interacting with the kid all day long and this kid is happy
and I'm seeing the direct effect of people nurturing their kid and developing
their kid as a project,
mentoring their kid.
The same way you would mentor someone about how to do martial arts the same way
you were mentored or someone about how to write or how to do mathematics.
You're,
you're developing a thing,
a thinking thing,
and that's what a human being in
and I can't fathom the a parent who would have this human being that is born of
them that would not want to engage at that level.
You know what it meaning that they only go,
I want to go to work and leave my three children in the care of some other
person who is not physically,
you know,
he was not responsible for them in,
in,
in the,
and the absolute way that I would be respond.
I can't even,
I can't even fathom that,
that mentality.
So I'm not trying to get parents off the hook with this theory,
but you also had an example of a perfectly,
uh,
well adjusted outstanding citizen and an upright citizen,
a human being who came from a horrible environment and let's not get carried
away.
He's not an outstanding human being fucked up.
He's a fighter fucked up.
I think what
I'm saying is this guy won't drink and he won't,
he won't look waste food.
And this is directly because of his whole childhood.
He's not a good guy.
He's in fact,
he's,
he's kind of abusive towards his children and he's got issues of his own.
He's not a good guy.
What I'm saying is there's a direct response to this guy living in this horrible
life as a child to him saying,
I am not going to be like that anymore.
I'm going to make sure I don't do drugs.
I'm gonna make sure I don't drink.
And this is because he lived in this horrible environment.
We saw the direct effects of someone being an alcoholic and whatnot.
But he's still,
he's a shitty parent,
you know?
I mean this is,
it's a very complex issue.
It's a very complex issue raising children and it's an issue where people
conveniently intelligent people conveniently like to skirt the responsibility of
what it is to raise their children.
And I see it from friends,
I see it from friends that work long hours and it's one of the reasons why I
choose to work much fewer hours than I could.
I want to be around,
I'm leaving from here,
I'm going to go pick up my kid and when I do that I'm going to hang out with
them and I'm going to play and we're going to have a good time and we're going
to talk about stuff.
And I think that's a responsibility that a parent has.
I think people evolve toward that.
And not only in terms of becoming a parent and your priorities change,
but like as as I get older I can kind of,
I can,
I can sense that happening and be like,
I want to work less.
I want to enjoy life and have
ambition is great.
It's great.
I mean it,
it allows us to become successful to the point where we would have less stress.
You have a nice home,
you have food on a table,
you can take care of your needs,
but when it gets past a certain point,
you know,
my friend Brian Cowen said it best.
He said,
you want to be successful enough where you don't worry about what it costs to go
out to dinner.
He goes after that.
It's all bullshit and it's,
he's right it,
I mean,
once you know,
you can have a nice meal and you don't worry about food,
you don't worry about having a roof over your head.
You don't have,
you don't have to live in a dangerous neighborhood.
You can afford to live in an area where you,
you know that your family and your loved ones are safe.
Other than that,
it's all bullshit.
Will you have a bigger house and then a bigger,
and now you have a castle.
Now you own an island and come on,
it's all mo money,
Mo problems.
Biggie said it right.
You know,
at a certain point in time it becomes you.
You,
you trap yourself with your own ambition and you get yourself into a situation
where you realize like,
oh,
this is not the smart way to do this.
I've just been caught up in this,
this zero sum game,
this idea that,
you know,
there's a,
there's a certain amount,
you know,
like you have to continue to grow.
You have to continue to expand.
Like,
like a corporation.
We just had,
you know,
we're coming,
we're coming out to la,
we make once a year we make the pilgrimage,
um,
you know,
be otherwise we work and live in Miami and we're coming out to la and it's like
we had a meeting and it's like this is on one hand it's like this is the most
important meeting of our careers.
And then I thought about it,
cause I like to do this sometimes just kind of flips something on its head and
go 180 degrees and say,
what if my belief is the exact,
what if the reality is he is the exact opposite of my belief.
So I said,
what if this is the least important meeting of our careers?
And it dawned on me,
it's like,
it's something kind of outside of our,
it's,
it's in the entertainment industry,
but it's kind of outside of our core competency
is nonfiction filmmakers.
And it certainly would advance us in the industry,
but I was just like,
if nothing comes of it or it doesn't go well,
this most important meeting of our careers,
we go home,
we go back to work making our documentaries.
I very little to complain about,
you know,
I,
I don't have to worry about where my next meal is gonna come from or where or if
I'm going to have a roof over my head,
I still got to work,
you know,
I said,
but we'll just keep doing what we've always been doing and what we're pretty
happy,
you know,
it pretty,
pretty happy in life.
Like what more do I actually,
well,
I love,
I love to be able to support my parents a little bit,
but like there's little things like that,
but like,
but beyond that,
it's just like,
so what happens if this most important meeting doesn't go well?
It's like life is still pretty good.
Like,
I don't have that much to,
to complain about all thing,
you know.
So yeah.
So I don't know if that's a product of being and 10 years ago I would have been
like on the,
I would have been like,
oh shit,
this is it.
Everything's riding on this if you,
and now I'm kinda like,
well but what if it doesn't go well?
It's like sly fix shit still good.
You grow,
you learn,
you just get better at functioning and you get better at coping with stress and
you also have a perspective of a long life.
You know,
you have this respective of many years of life on this planet and learning the
lessons.
I was thinking about that with the,
you know,
we were talking about the heavyweights getting older and Kimbo being forward
what we said 41 and know and uh,
I'm thinking,
cause we did this dock for ESPN called broke about professional athletes going
broke and exactly what you just described,
which is like the natural or typical trajectory of an American.
It's like you're born,
you go to school,
you learn a trade.
Presumably you graduate and enter the workforce.
You enter,
you're obviously at the,
at the entry level,
you start to work your way up in said industry or pivot to something else or
whatever it is,
but in the meantime you get married.
Maybe you get divorced,
maybe get married again.
You make some investments,
some good,
some bad.
You buy a house,
you have a mortgage,
maybe you have a foreclosure,
you get some experience.
You start to learn as you grow and as you grow and advance in an industry,
you're making more money hopefully,
and then by the time you're saying in your 50s you're at the peak of your
powers.
You are making the most,
you're going to make a and then you retire and that entire structure is
completely upside down for a professional athlete because they're going to make
the most money they're ever going to make in their lives.
It basically in their 20s even if you're a sort of premium mode,
they are the most successful criminal crime,
like,
like top 1% of a professional athletes.
Because the other thing that people don't understand in,
in,
in this,
in this business is that like,
and that sports and entertainment is that like not everybody is a millionaire.
People don't understand that.
Like,
not a lot of sport professional athletes are journeymen,
you know,
they make decent money or they make league minimum,
whatever it is,
but they still have to work,
you know,
they can't just retire tomorrow and be okay.
And,
and that's the thing about when people see that you,
you know,
oh,
you make movies,
your shit's on showtime or your,
I see your stuff all the time.
Right.
You know,
you're very,
you have a,
you have a check on Twitter.
It's like,
you must be,
you must be a millionaire.
There's like this incredible misconception that like in my line of work that
like,
uh,
we're rich and famous and we are like neither of those things,
you know.
But like I see I should be returned that fucking documentary from cocaine
cowboys.
If you didn't get rich somebody,
fuck.
The most money I've ever made in the drug industry is selling my urine to my
friends cause I was the only guy that didn't smoke or didn't do drug and the
drug industry.
Yeah.
Meaning like my friends would like,
they made more than that than you did from cocaine cowboys.
Yeah.
No,
I never sold my urine.
Good bread.
Good friends can be like,
dude,
do you,
you,
my employer is going to start retesting if you,
uh,
you know,
if,
if you,
if you say you sold me some some,
but uh,
but it's,
you're like,
I was a kid growing up that never,
I didn't treat you well.
I was 21 I've ever done coke.
No,
no,
never.
Never.
Adderall.
A half an Adderall ones for the show.
No,
no,
no.
It's a good guess though.
Salad.
I eat gum before that.
Before the show energy gum or jolt Cola Gum.
Oh yeah,
don't do that.
That's a bad,
you're going to have a heart attack sweating a little bit.
Yeah,
that's true.
Plus you're going to crash at the end of this.
You're going to need a nap.
No,
no,
Tom,
I'm an la dude.
The pulse of this city
stops.
Yeah,
go,
stop,
stop.
So I said go,
go,
stop,
stop.
Stop the pulse of this city.
Yeah.
Um,
so when you were doing cocaine cowboys,
did you ever have any desire to do coke to see what the fuss is all about?
No,
in fact,
what,
it's interesting,
I went to an arts high school and so,
and this is the mid nineties,
early,
early to mid nineties.
So,
you know,
drug trends,
I find like nostalgic trends are cyclical.
Like there are certain perennials like Potts always popular.
Um,
but like in the mid nineties,
it was back to like sixties trucks again.
People were doing,
my friends were doing like psychedelics,
they were doing acid,
shrooms,
good for the sea was ecstasy was like in a similar genre.
So MDA was on the rise.
Then a high school kids couldn't afford cocaine,
but that wasn't as popular as it later became in the and the aughts,
you know,
in the Zeros again,
I mean that that trend was coming around,
but like,
um,
I was just never curious to kind of alter my mind,
my will,
my partners and I started our first company.
We were sophomores in high school,
so I was like working,
I was like sort of goal oriented and then I was like,
I was raised to believe that like you go to school and then you go to college
and you know you and you had a car when I think it was my junior year when I had
friends in high school,
I had friends who are seniors and for the first time in my life I learned that
not everybody goes to college.
That was the first time I knew that because I was just raised to believe that
that's just the natural course of life.
I had friends who were,
like I said,
we're an arts high school.
We're going to go,
I'm going to New York and I'm going to be a dancer and I'm going to go to La and
I'm going to do,
and I was like for college.
And they're like,
not at all.
I'm gonna get an apartment,
but some fram.
And that was like a foreign concept to me.
So I was like the straight arrogant.
I was a kid who finally got the respect that we would sit around in a circle and
they'd be passing the joint and they would just pass it like around me.
You know,
they would know not to even when you're in a room.
Yeah,
we,
but we'd be like in a garage would be at a bat or,
but no,
usually we're in a back yard and usually we're in the back.
I'm sure I've gotten that second hand stolen.
Must have.
I've seen people get fucked up on weed,
but like,
like,
like have panic attacks in this room.
I didn't know.
I thought it was supposed to be like this chill high.
Like this mellow.
I,
Timothy leary had a great expression about weed,
uh,
not about a,
we'd rather about LSD,
that La,
that LSD a induces states of paranoia and psychosis and people that have never
tried it like that.
People are terrified of LSD.
And you know,
just the way the coke,
I mean,
like I told him I did coke,
you'd have to scrape me off the fucking ceiling with a shovel or like a rake or
something.
Cause I would just like,
I would just like be crazy.
Like this is how I am normally,
you know,
with some caffeine.
I just,
I was always,
I wasn't afraid.
I was always just like,
I'm not going to have a positive reaction to this.
And I,
and I don't know that the prohibition has ever been a deterrent because
obviously drugs are quite of readily available in,
in,
in Miami,
uh,
in particular,
believe it or not seen and still not as big of a coke scene.
But like Molly is,
you know,
a big now,
certainly we'd,
the biggest pond Molly is like the nicest people to be around.
The difference between people that are on Molly,
they want to rub you,
then want to come over and hold the hands of you,
the friendly that will hug the biggest concern.
Like shut the fuck up.
He's concerned.
He was like,
what are you actually ingesting?
Like who are you buying it from?
You?
What did they cut it with?
Which is the problem with the illegality.
Illegality.
The prohibition creates that.
The poison for sure man.
I mean all these fucking people that are smoking fake weed,
they're smoking this spice stuff and all this.
Oh it's awful for you.
You don't even know what you're adjusting your lungs.
Your body doesn't know what to do with it.
It's alien,
you know the,
the cannabinoid receptors.
Like what the fuck is this?
You know,
it's like the same argument against artificial sweeteners but to a much
heightened,
a much more heightened level because though the way it's interacting with your
mind,
it's,
you know,
I just think,
again,
I think it's,
it's,
it's traces marijuana prohibition.
It's like traces of this kind of like,
and we were talking about earlier,
this idea that you can't get past pass it.
If you objectively analyze,
we're talking about Trayvon Zimmerman,
you've just objectively analyze the facts of the situation.
There's really only one reality there and,
and it's,
it's incredible to me how people,
how race gets in the way of blocking their access to that reality.
But it seems to me the marijuana prohibition,
it's a plant that grows out of the earth that is less dangerous than poison ivy,
which is legal,
although I wouldn't smoke it or recommending it was real hard time being
objective about issues that are hot button issues.
You know,
whether it's drugs,
whether it's religion,
whether it's a that you have these drug dealers in lab coats at the,
at the local pharmacy.
Okay.
Who are killing children,
not them per,
but like these pharmaceutical companies were creating poisoned toxic chemicals
that people,
because a doctor writes you a prescription for it,
gleefully hand it to their wives,
their kids,
their parents.
Like that is a,
that is a mindset that's like ingrained us as a result of just like a life of,
of propaganda and,
and,
and just ma mind fucking,
I mean,
it just,
it's literally just brainwashing that you could think,
oh,
this plant that grows out of the ground,
you shouldn't roll that in.
Smoke it.
We do it with cigars,
we do it with cigarettes.
But as soon as you start adding crazy shit to it,
like nicotine or chemicals or that's,
that makes it legal because the FDA is to,
oh,
I don't,
I just don't understand stamps.
It says,
I mean alcohol,
one of the most devastating drugs.
So why are people okay with it by,
it's because people are okay with culture.
When culture is firmly established and you grow up in that environment,
it seems normal to put a fucking plate in your lips and stretch your lips out.
It seems normal to put a bone through your nose.
Why?
Because all the elders,
they have the scar effication on their face.
I'm going to get scarred up too.
I mean,
that's what everybody does.
It's or atmosphere to pay the government 25 cents to make a dime.
Like we were talking about earlier,
without laws about cops enforcing laws that are just essentially revenue
collecting laws and not protecting anybody from anything.
There was two kids at barely teenagers,
you know,
they had the snow day out east in Iowa with the blizzard a couple of weeks ago.
And so instead of sitting around dicking around at home,
because it wasn't nearly as bad as everyone thought it was going to be,
they decided instead of watching TV or playing video games,
right or no smoking the pot,
they said,
let's grab a couple of shovels,
go door to door and make five bucks and offered,
uh,
to clean people's,
you know,
to a driveways.
And the cops came because they got complaints.
The kids were knocking on doors or whatever,
I guess,
and stopped the,
they didn't have a proper permit offer offering their services.
I did that all throughout my childhood.
When I was a kid.
We would get psyched when it would snow.
Now,
me and my friends would go around the neighborhood and we shovel and we'd make
deals.
Do they shut down?
Lemonade stands now for not having proper permitting in licenses.
That's ridiculous.
And that's,
that's the,
the,
the revenue collecting aspect that we were talking about.
They're not about withholding.
Upholding the piece are protecting or serving New Jersey teens block from
shoveling snow without permit cunts.
That's all that is.
Jersey Jersey is a state where people can't even put your own gas for crying out
loud.
Does it say the cop's name so we could say it on the
police chief Michael Giannone told my Jersey central.com to two teens would not
arrested.
All issued a ticket.
But what stopped because the town was in a so called state of emergency in
adventure.
A comics dump.
Shut the fuck up.
Emergency Central Jersey.
Some burns.
That's my whole page.
That's where you can't shovel snow because it's going to be more snow out.
Yeah.
Good.
Good call fucking ass.
This is what you're saying about before.
These are the rules on the,
on the books for forcing.
They're not making up these laws.
The cops.
They're just prop a permit for shovel and there's a permit for helping pizza get
out of it.
Didn't or is that jersey?
Whatever it is.
If
you'd shovel someone for free,
is that okay?
Oh,
it's just be exchange of money.
You know?
That's what it is.
You,
you,
you could go around the neighborhood is a good Samaritan.
Shovel everybody out,
but the cops were never a problem with that.
If you're not giving,
the government did.
Like I said,
if you're not paying the government 25 cents to make a dime because how much of
these kids going to make that they could go out and spend,
I don't know,
$300 on a permit so that for one day on a snow day when they're not at school,
they could go around and make five bucks a driveway.
Like it's unsafe.
Cops should investigate really hot women,
the date these old decrepit old men that are barely alive and they drive around
a rolls Royces and shit.
You should be like,
Ho Ho,
Ho,
Ho.
Let's sit down.
Sit down.
Let's talk.
What do you,
what are you getting out of this?
You're getting money.
He give you that rolls.
I want 25% of that roles.
What?
That roles was worth.
$250,000 pay up hooker.
Why take 25% they can just use asset forfeiture and take the whole thing.
Yeah.
That girl is a whore.
She should give up that money.
Give up that fucking car.
Bitch.
You know,
you don't look that old man that sees it.
Like if you had like Anna Nicole Smith and her husband remember that piece
before he died.
Yeah.
Both of them.
Right.
She's dead too.
And that crazy.
But like,
I mean,
that was one of the more clear examples of public prostitution.
You're ever gonna see a billionaire j Howard Marshall and a big pride hooker.
I mean,
that's,
that's what it was.
And you,
you have one that's profiting off of the other.
When you go to the,
uh,
the seminal hard rock and Hollywood,
Florida at the Improv,
you don't,
you don't stay in the end,
in a kol sweet.
There's an anarchist.
Sweet.
She died there.
Oh,
that's,
there's ghosts.
Ghosts of favorite cities.
There was a rumor the Seminoles would never confirm this but there was,
there was a rumor that they actually sent like a witch doctor or like something
to like to kind of go spa di poltergeist or whatever.
The room and then they like completely redid the room.
Changed the number like that.
That's the room.
No,
they would never come that dotted or confirm that she was so dumb.
I better ghost would be too stupid to haunt me buddy.
I bet her ghost be like,
oop,
no boo.
Ooh Fuck it.
I quit.
It goes from just take naps or ghost,
just take naps and do pills.
Imagine if he just,
he saw a ghost of like a fat chick eating pills on the couch.
Like it's like such a nonthreatening ghost.
Especially like on seminal land.
It'd be like,
she would be like the least scary ghost and like Indian burial ground about
that.
You're talking about native Americans are not just persecuted but they were in
genocide,
was committed upon their people and as a compensation they were given swats of
language.
Are they going to open up casinos?
I mean,
it's mad.
I said the Indian casinos are,
the payment saying is the house always wins like Indian casinos,
the only casino where the house never wins because no matter how much money you
lose,
we still rape their women and stole their country.
So it's like,
call it reparations,
like sit down at the one arm bandit and lose some money for crying out loud.
Like it's,
it's,
it's but meaning,
but what's interesting is it like now,
and this might be a,
this might go to you to,
to your earlier point,
that it's Affluenza.
There's,
they're like no native Americans that work at these casinos anymore.
They sit at home,
get the check every month from the,
the revenue and now they're hiring white boys to wrestle out alligators and like
do all that.
Like,
you know,
the,
the Indian cultural,
native American rather cultural shit.
And there's no,
no Indians and an Indian casino anymore.
They're all just kind of living off the fat of the land and getting their checks
and not incentivized to motivate or,
or,
or do anything.
And you see higher rates of alcoholism,
of drug abuse and,
and they're just sitting around,
you know,
getting checks and,
and,
and uh,
and a lot of them are dying.
Well that's always been an issue on native American reservations,
right?
Alcoholism.
Absolutely.
Depression,
drug abuse,
depression.
I mean their culture was stolen.
I mean it's like essentially they're wiped out except for a few survivors who
are then forced to assimilate and there's new strange culture and then made
aware of it painfully every step of the way.
And when you're growing up that you were,
you're the loser in this cultural genocide attack and this,
these are the people,
those are unconquered they always reminded us,
they always say,
well,
the Seminoles actually do a lot of good things.
They use that money and a lot of good ways.
And they're,
they,
they support a lot of charities like that,
that tribe and Florida is responsible for a lot of good things.
You'd,
they bought one of the most American brands,
the hardware,
like talk about the ultimate fuck you.
Like we own the hard rock,
but I'm not,
that was me.
I'm like,
what a great,
great thing.
That club too.
I work at the club every time I'm down there.
I prefer that club over the,
the bigger one in West Palm,
which I get more money on.
I like,
it's like a more intimate environment I find go there and I sacrifice a little
money and I have a better time sometimes.
Like my girlfriend was doing a project for school a few months ago and it was
about the appropriation of native American culture and how it's one of the few
races where it's still okay.
It's the whole red skins phenomenon,
you know,
like how it's still okay to be racist and to create kind of like Minstrel esque
images of their children dressed in skins like India can Redskins.
That's like having the n word.
That's the equivalent,
but people don't look at it that way.
I just don't understand how they don't just change the name.
It's not a difficult thing and do it.
Look,
if you want to honor native Americans and somehow or another keep like that,
you can just change the name,
you know,
call it you,
you could call it whatever.
I mean there's people that call it the warrior's.
So the Golden State Warriors,
right?
Like there no ones have,
no,
I don't think if they do have an issue with that,
they're being silly.
Yeah.
Cause that's an honorables.
I mean that's like you're,
you're,
you're being proud of what these people were at their finest are at their most
noble and powerful,
still get offended by the mascot tree though know.
And that's a real kind of like,
like white guilt moment for me because I'm a rights activists to get offended by
any mascots.
You're always going to have some people that are ridiculous,
but red skin is a little weird man.
It's like,
I didn't really think about it that way,
but it's incredibly offensive.
Yeah.
I saw,
yeah,
I saw it earlier.
That's offensive.
You fuck wild thing.
Good worthwhile thing.
Yeah.
I just,
I wasn't,
that was something I was completely,
I don't want to say it was insensitive to it.
It's just kind of unaware of it.
And then she starts doing this like pow,
this whole PowerPoint on it actually starts going and getting like racist
iconography through through the years,
particularly in the south and from,
you know,
we're in Miami and Florida and like,
and I was like,
and she was kind of putting them,
she was doing side by side comparisons to like classic,
you know,
pre civil rights era,
racist advertising and uh,
you know,
and,
and posters and imagery in art and then contemporary native American depictions
left and right.
And I'm like,
Oh shit.
I was like,
yeah,
how can we not see that?
That's like,
that was that,
that,
that racist,
you know,
a,
a black,
you know,
the,
the black cartoon face with the great big lip seeding a watermelon.
That was okay once you can advertise your store or your product,
answer mine,
mine,
that kind of Shit.
Yeah.
And then she's got the same exact or reminiscent imagery,
but from like contemporary ads and cattle,
again,
kids dressed up is as Indians and what the fate with the war paint and the head
dress.
And,
and,
and the kind of,
and kind of comparing that to modern day a a minstrel.
And I'm like,
that's fast.
And like I just never thought about it that way.
And then privilege as a white man,
I started to feel a whole fucking bad about it again.
And I'm like,
I'm the asshole.
I never thought about this before and I'm an asshole for never having kids.
But like Redskins,
he's like,
I'm seeing it.
I'm actually going like,
oh shit.
Should I be saying the r word?
Like I'm actually now in that headspace because of white guilt.
Yes.
It's definitely not necessary.
I mean,
look,
you could still have the same exact team,
the same exact athletes,
the same exact pride and just let's get together and have a contest to come up
with a new name and you would,
you would get people that would be so happy about and the publicity from that
contest to look.
And I'm like,
we're going to keep it out of tradition.
And because our fans aren't offended by,
it's like we had slavery out of tradition.
For one thing,
a black lady that looks like a slave on the cover of their,
yes.
Jesus fucking Christ.
How's that happening?
That's,
that's the thing.
Well,
I catch him.
I'm a doc.
I think she's,
I think she's the woman who,
uh,
who actually created the,
the citizen,
but she's a lovely,
she's different.
She's not all dressed like the main,
like the mammy,
like the maid.
And she likes to be a mammy though.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
it was like right out of antebellum south.
It was like a gone with the wind character.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And,
and uh,
yeah,
she's lovely.
She's a lovely working woman.
She has regular hair now too.
She used to have that Bandanna over a hair.
Well,
she wouldn't get her dirty hair and the white man's food.
Yeah.
This is what she used to look like,
man.
Good Lord.
Oh my God.
Your Mama used to look like a slave.
That's why.
That's why the updated Wendy,
you know,
cause the ginger protest movement was trying to get Wendy of Wendy's.
No,
I'm just,
oh,
but I,
but the right heads,
not the Redskins with the red.
Well,
that's what I'm wondering.
I'm wondering like are we,
at what point is,
does it be,
are we veering into political correctness?
I think the red skins thing is tooth going too far.
I really believe that.
You mean in a,
in a negative way.
I don't think we're being overly sensitive is what I'm saying.
No,
I don't think so.
I think it's fucked up.
I think if you were a native American it would be a huge issue.
It would be very much like,
you know,
if you had the fucking San Francisco guineas,
you know the mascot was a fucking Italian guy with a hairy chest and gold chains
looking stupid with pasta stains on his shirt would be jersey.
That would be San Francisco.
Well,
you know,
there's a lot of guineas in San Francisco,
believe it or not.
Really?
Is that a thing?
Is there,
is there like a little Italy?
Is there like one of the,
yeah,
there's a lot of Italian people in San Francisco,
so I was just going to sound fucking amazing.
Italian food.
Yes.
Pam on Columbus Avenue right here.
Getting some of my life.
They're very good Chinese food but very good Italian food to San Francisco is
really good there.
There's some jam in Italian restaurants we eat at every time we worked there.
I was complaining about have you ever driven in San Francisco is treacherous
dude,
these fucking treacherous,
easy,
well grew up in Boston son.
Oh yeah.
I grew up in Miami,
grew up on black ice sea level.
We're at sea level.
There's no hint that you know,
the highest elevation in the state is mount Trashmore.
It's a,
it's a landfill that is the highest elevation.
How and appropriately,
uh,
when they did that movie rock of ages,
that was the hot,
they put the Hollywood sign,
I'm out.
Sure.
That's where they did funding.
We say in Florida,
the only thing you can't really recreate is like mountains and snow.
But,
but they found a way to do it.
I met,
I don't know how high it is,
but that's the highest point of elevation in Florida.
It's all trash mount Trashmore it's a landfill that they're just,
yeah,
they're just piling on.
But,
but I grew up,
when I went to San Francisco was the scariest thing in my eye.
What we were actually doing cocaine cowboys to hustling with the godmother in,
in,
uh,
in Oakland,
in Brookfield village.
And I had to,
I had to drive the equipment truck back and return the equipment at the end of
that shoot.
So I'm driving in this great big truck with like,
I dunno,
untold thousands of dollars worth of equipment that I've got to return to this
house.
And I was just petrified.
Why?
Cause I was like,
I was like looking straight.
Oh,
the hill hills dude.
Did you ever see bullet with Steve Mcqueen?
Of course.
I watched it again a couple of weeks or a couple of months ago.
Uh,
it was a,
a trip in Canada and I was watching it with a friend who had never seen it
before.
I was like,
dude,
you're in front God damn treat.
This is a real American movie and it's also a movie where there's very little
dialogue.
It's a great movie man.
Bullet with Steve McQueen's,
a great muscle.
Seventies were like the last golden age of American cinema.
There was,
when she got real front,
when Shit got real there were definitely different.
It was a completely different style of making a movie.
Back then you didn't have to have music and every God damn scene,
you know,
you had some real moments,
gritty,
gritty and like,
and I think they were just coming out of,
of,
you know,
the 60s with that transition where in terms of censorship where you could start
getting a,
what you start pushing the envelope in the 60s by the 70s there was no envelope
anymore and just mainstream cinema,
you can do practically anything.
And they did.
And so you,
you,
you had,
and that wasn't just in terms of like a sex and violence,
but in terms of the reality and the grittiness of the stories and the
characters,
it'd be shit became really dirty.
Harry.
Like those early dirty Harry movies are like brutal,
but they're dumb.
The difference between that and like bullet bullet is a brilliant movie.
It's like the people that are in it,
they're great actors.
It feels real.
You know,
like there's some dirty hairy moments where you're like,
go ahead,
make my day.
I come on Fuck Outta here.
Crazy asshole.
No,
it's like they're fun,
but you know,
it's a fun movie to watch,
but it doesn't give you a feeling like you're actually watching something that
could actually be taken place.
But it's brutal.
It is brutal.
Yeah.
Man.
It was just raw death.
Wish to see the first one.
Yeah.
Charles Bronson,
man.
Yeah.
The first one,
not so much.
Well,
there's,
yeah,
those,
they start selling on his face started getting fatter.
He starts again.
I make cocaine cowboys to hustle.
The God mother.
I can't complain about one man.
I mean,
the,
you parked to stand.
Why the cocaine cowboys to keep apologizing for that cocaine cowboys one you
have no apologies.
Right?
No,
I mean,
there's certainly things I do differently.
We got to do cocaine cowboys,
reloaded,
which was great.
Uh,
you know,
no,
there was nothing wrong with it.
Um,
did someone forced you to call it hustling with the godmother?
Is that what's up?
I think it's,
I think what happens is you have a lot of temporary working titles that just
stick.
Like our first doc,
we did this,
it's nothing wrong with it.
We did this dot called raw deal,
a question of consent.
And that was raw deal was just our working title and it was about the alleged
rape of a stripper at the Delta Chi Fraternity House at the University of
Florida in Gainesville.
And the spring of 99 and the entire night's events are captured on two video
cameras.
And so we use the video footage and then we interview the stripper and we
interviewed some of the fraternity men.
So the thing about the,
the footage is that,
um,
it was placed in the public record of some of these very liberal public record
laws we have in Florida.
So it was placed in the public record and it became like the cost Leben
Gainesville,
Gainesville is a small town,
so there was still live there.
Did you really live there?
When I was a little kid between the age of seven and 11 I lived in Gainesville
county resident going to the University of Florida,
so I was down there.
I used to go to Lake Alice and Crockett or the alligators marshmallows before
they made it.
Yeah.
Well they were in the Ocala national forest.
You might be familiar.
And they were doing a big brother,
little brother pledge event.
I didn't rush.
I'm not,
I wasn't,
it wasn't in the Greek world,
but good for you.
Some ritual where there there's a bonfire.
I don't know what the hell is.
Anything that needs to be boycotted.
Boycott that showed kids enough.
That'd be your own fucking man.
Quick flash forward.
We premiered at Sundance film fest one then later went to the Edinburgh film
fest where it's like the,
it's like the Sundance of Europe and like,
so we go to Edinburgh and all the questions,
which is kind of interesting because most of the questions,
and Erica were about this,
this controversy,
which we'll get into in a minute,
but all,
almost all the questions
in Edinburgh were about what the hell the Greek system is.
They don't have it there,
so they were completely,
this was like a total,
it was a nat Geo doc for them.
They were like,
what is this green?
You know,
like what is the attorneys and I'm like the least qualified person to be at,
you know to we talk about that.
Then when you go to,
when you go to the University of Miami,
which I did and I was a Miami Guy,
like you don't need to,
for the,
for social interaction,
you don't need a club like you might need to do in Gainsville or Tallahassee or
these college towns,
these insulated college towns where you're,
the social environment is very kind of restricted.
This hazing and all the fucking crib,
dude,
fuck all that's creepy.
So they're hazing these kids or whatever.
This ritual,
the big brother,
little brother,
pledge ritual out in the forest.
They go back to the,
to the,
to the fraternity house to the common area,
and they have two strippers that they hired to come and perform.
One of the strippers leaves after the show,
one of the strippers goes back to for a private party with some of the
fraternity men,
uh,
come the dawn,
she goes running to a neighboring fraternity house.
Her Grant,
a grandmother was actually a house mom of one of the,
she thought this was the house that her mother or grandmother worked at.
It wasn't,
but she's wearing nothing but a t shirt that belong to one of the fraternity men
coming up to about her belly button and banging on the door of this neighboring
house saying that she had been raped.
And she told the university police department that they had videotaped it and
they go and get the videotape footage and spoiler alert,
watch one of the two videotapes and arrest of the stripper for filing a false
police report based on the videotape footage.
And as a result of that,
one of the two videos,
what about the second video?
I didn't care,
but there's a second video saying an actual rape.
The second videotape,
as it turns out,
was just coverage of,
it was like eight Cam B Cam.
So the second videotape doesn't show that much more.
It just shows alternate angles of the same action rather than,
but so,
so what happens is there's now a misdemeanor filing,
a false police report case against this woman.
And as a result,
the media says,
well,
we want to see,
this is evidence in a criminal case.
Her lawyer argues that under rape shield laws,
that her identity should be protected in her,
uh,
in this video tape put,
it should be to protect you because it depicts a rape.
A judge viewed the footage and says,
this ain't no rape.
And they release the footage to the public and they're in there becomes,
there's a backlog at the state attorney's office and the clerk of courts there,
cause there's like,
they're like making copies,
the video tape and sending it to people.
So in Gainesville,
if you were the first person on your block to get the tape,
what they called the rape tape,
you'd have a kegger.
People would invite friends over to their house.
And they too,
cause you were the first person to get in.
Everybody wanted to see it.
So what happens is like
growing up in Miami,
you got friends of course,
who go to Gainesville,
go to Tallahassee.
And I'll go to the,
the two major state schools of course,
only in Florida to our two flagship state schools where they both,
uh,
targets of major serial killers,
Ted Bundy and Tallahassee and Danny Rollin and university of fluid only in
Florida.
Um,
and so we hear from a friend,
so I'll never forget this,
as long as I live,
we hear from one of our friends and we grew up,
same neighborhood.
I say that same upbringing,
white middle class Jewish kids.
I see that to say we had similar kind of life and come come at things with a not
dissimilar worldview.
So they said,
did you hear this is like summer of 99 by now?
And they're like,
did you hear about this case with Delta Chi and the stripper and the video?
I said,
yeah,
yeah.
I read about it and,
and they're like,
I just saw the videotape at a friend's house.
I was like,
well,
what happened?
And,
and my friends like,
he's like,
it was disgusting what they do to this poor woman.
Like I haven't been able to eat or sleep for days.
It's horrible what they put her through,
how they talked to her,
how they put her down,
how they hold her down.
She's tried kicking and trying to get away and I can't believe they haven't
arrested these guys and it's just,
I'm just completely distraught over it.
And then days later I hear from another buddy again.
We all grew up together.
Same store,
same grip.
He,
I said,
what?
he said,
did you hear about their lives?
Of course you saw,
I just heard,
yeah,
he's like this lying slut.
I was,
she's screwing around with all these guys and then she cries rape.
They should lock her up and throw away the key.
And I'm like,
what on earth?
You have to,
did you see the tape before this?
No,
not before this.
I'd only heard about it from these guys.
And I'm like two reasonable educated,
similar demo.
Guys Watch the same footage and diametrically disagree about whether or not they
witnessed a consensual or nonconsensual sex act.
And I'm like,
we got to see this footage.
So in a sense it's analogous,
this Trayvon Martin thing and the sort of way,
but you can,
you actually have a video,
but you have the video to predisposed to the Duke Lacrosse case,
the Duke Lacrosse case,
which they never turns out,
they never touched the girl.
A lot of the guys were alibied.
One guy was at an ATM machine,
make no withdrawal while the woman claims that he was raping her.
Um,
but here you had sexual intercourse.
Unquestionably.
Undeniably.
Here was video tape footage of the sexual intercourse.
Your take on what actually happened.
You got to see the movie.
He decided,
no,
I'm going to send it to you.
We don't have much time left to just tell me because you have to tell me like
what do you think?
What I think is is that you have one of the most oft committed,
least reported crimes in like the history of man and most of these crimes as
they say or not like the mass man in the bushes.
Stranger rape makes up the minority of rape.
It's mostly be assertive.
It's mostly acquaintance or date rape.
What I think though is that you have a world where we expect videotape footage
to tell an objective truth,
to say,
here's the surveillance video.
There is the guy robbing the store.
Let's go find him.
Case closed.
When you have a crime like this that exists predominantly in the minds of the
alleged victim and alleged perpetrator,
it's almost impossible to determine because not all,
you know what,
what,
what.
What she claims is like,
this wasn't a a Hollywood rate.
This wasn't me kicking and screaming and crying going,
no,
no.
She was a professional stripper.
She had been most of her life.
And she comes from a world where we spoke to a rape crisis counselor who,
who,
whose office was near strip color,
close to a lot of strip clubs in Florida.
And he found a lot of professional girls,
so to speak,
who would come in and they're always trying to maintain a line,
you know,
this is what these are,
you don't ever got a lap dance.
Like here are the rules.
I can touch you.
You can it.
And then over the course of the thing,
depending on how much money is spent,
the law,
the lines get blurred.
You get,
you know,
there's certain things,
there's certain compromises that are made.
And so what happens here is that over the course of a long night,
she had danced at like three or four players.
There's like our third or fourth show last one of the night.
She,
um,
she partied with the guy she was drinking,
they were drinking.
They might've even been rolling on.
There's a lot of that line gets seriously blurred and what point can you,
you know at any point if a woman doesn't want,
if there was,
I,
I pull the audience,
and this is really interesting too because like I would call it the worst date
movie of all time.
I pull the audience,
we always assume that like the women would side with her and the men would side
with the men very often it's the exact opposite of that and the men are more
inclined to believe her and the women are more inclined to believe the men
because they don't want to,
they don't want to.
The behavior from both parties is pretty reprehensible depending on your morals
and values or some people,
it's a Tuesday night when brothers,
it's like this is appalling.
I don't want to associate my genders behavior with that behavior.
Not to say she deserves or anything,
but like people really want to dismiss.
It's interesting,
I talked to Roy Black and I know of the famous defense attorney.
One of his most famous clients was William Kennedy Smith,
the famous rape trial in Palm beach at the Kennedy compound.
And,
uh,
Roy Black going in.
Um,
the Kennedys were like,
well,
we need Kennedy Democrats on this jury obviously.
And the jury consultant came in and said,
no,
what you need is middle age or older white Republican women because their
values,
they're going to look at this,
this woman goes out with this man drinking and dining.
They go,
she goes back to his place at whatever ungodly hour of the night.
And what does she expect will happen.
That's much more the mentality of not Kennedy Democrats,
but they wound up going with that jury.
Not only did he get acquitted but Roy Black married the jury.
The jury for woman is lay a black,
if you're familiar with the,
the real housewives of my,
I'm sure you're an advocate for real.
Yeah,
I know.
Um,
the real housewives of Miami,
if you took nothing of that,
you took one guy.
If you took one part of each of the housewives,
you might be able to build one real one I think.
But like that's,
but that's,
anyway,
that's,
so we,
the men and women diametrically like our sort of opposed.
And then you have a situation where I pull the audience and I'll say,
how many of you believe she was raped?
How many of you believe she wasn't raped?
How many of you believe that some sexual activity occurred?
That she didn't consent to,
that she didn't want to happen?
Most people raise their hands.
I'm like,
well,
that under the law is right,
but how do you find a jury of 12 people that are,
that is going to convict based on Herbie.
This is what the social justice warrior websites,
they were just,
they were judging the pole.
They were judging her behavior.
And I'll tell you something I read in this case,
I'm with them.
Well,
I'm,
I'm reading the police report,
which was like a 70 page police report on a misdemeanor filing.
False police
report against her,
the case against the woman for filing a false police report.
And the woman who wrote it,
the detective,
um,
I ice thought it revealed more about her than,
than anybody else.
But she,
there's,
there's one phrase I'll never forget in all of these pages.
She writes,
um,
uh,
the woman went to Dan,
said all of these houses,
uh,
leaving her two children who are black at home with a babysitter or with their
mother or something like that.
And I was like,
who are just those three words?
who can,
she had been married to?
Her ex husband was a black man.
They had two children together.
And I was like,
what?
How in the world you live in Alachua County?
I don't know if that means something to people there,
but I was like,
how does,
how,
how is that have any,
who are,
is it her children who are black,
who are left to Polish at like her children who are Russian,
her children who are like,
I've never seen,
I'm like,
what are we trying,
what are we,
what's the implication or what's the relevance of this in a,
in a criminal proceeding.
But the,
I will put it you this way,
the people leave.
I over the course of working on the movie,
I changed my mind several times over the course of watching the movie and as you
live life and get more life experience it cause people come to this movie with
their own baggage.
I've seen,
I've had Q and A's where women get up to the microphone and say,
I've never said this before.
I was the victim of a rape on campus and start talking.
It's a very,
can be a very cathartic experience.
Can Be very disturbing either people can't even watch it.
Common.
I mean,
but it's also come false rape claims are also very calm.
They're not,
they're not common.
Not Common.
Rape claims happen all the time.
They're not common.
What do you mean by not common there?
There,
there,
there are my,
they're a minority of of rape claims.
I agree with that.
However they still common.
Yes,
and extraordinarily damaging to everybody involved but common.
No,
I don't.
What do you mean by not coming well?
I think rape.
What percentage is not common?
I think did if they happen every day and they do,
is that not common?
I think,
I think you're talking,
yes,
it's common,
but you're talking about single digits I think.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not talking about majority.
Okay.
Now talking about that.
I'm talking about they occur regularly then they're just common,
right?
Yes.
That they occur regularly and that must be taken if you're going to look into
some completely objectively.
Yes,
you are.
Well you're,
you know,
you're being sensitive to the victims,
which is very important.
But if you look at it objectively and it just as strictly as an a numerical
issue,
I mean I,
I believe the numbers like 8% I think that's the statistically proven number as
far as like investigated claims of,
right.
I think it's lower,
but it is single digits.
Yes.
I think it's the same.
It probably varies.
And then there's also the,
the,
the reality that a lot of rapes go unreported because women are ashamed of what
happened and they would rather just ignore it because they're going to be
accused of false reporting and their entire past and sexual experience is going
to be brought to bear.
And Yeah,
there's a lot.
And there's also,
you also have to take any consideration.
A lot of false rape claims.
The guys get convicted and it's never proven.
That's a false rape claim.
That's a fact.
I've had that happen to a friend.
I know that it works both ways.
Human beings are we,
you know,
there's people that are full of shit and they're men and there's people that are
full of shit that are women,
so there's,
there's always going to be that possibility that it's a false racial.
Gender has the greatest percentage of people full of Shit.
No,
I'm just fine.
It's across the board.
Probably.
Probably 50% across the board.
You don't even think I was just fucking with you,
Matt.
Maybe men because men,
well,
no,
because men try harder to fuck women,
so maybe we have to be because women were pursued.
We have to be more full of shit.
I think that's more possible.
I don't know.
That's a good question.
That's a good documentary subject.
What?
Gender is more full of Shit.
It's a great title.
Yeah,
it's a great title.
What gender is more full of Shit.
That's,
that's not a bad idea.
I think you're right.
I think that we're going to find it's pretty,
it's pretty close.
It's pretty close.
But you know,
the,
the rape thing as far as like,
you know what,
I think there's way more raped and there is falsely accused Vic,
you know,
false false rape claims.
Well I,
and,
and in this spirit of,
of justice and the spirit of,
you know,
let,
let 10 mil e t let 10 guilty men go free than one innocent man spend,
you know,
a moment being deprived of his liberty.
I mean,
I,
I under,
I understand that and I gotta say no matter how low the rate is,
2% according to Wikipedia,
that no matter how low that is,
the 2% of men that,
that the false claims occurred to,
it's pretty fucking important to them.
I can imagine.
Oh yeah.
But in those cases,
it's one 10th of 1% of its you.
And in those,
in the vast majority of those cases,
I believe it has to do with some sort of like,
you know,
mental deficiency on the part of the woman.
It has to do with some sort of revenge kind of scenario.
You know,
like the motive is like really personal and really obvious.
Um,
and can usually be quickly proven,
but as soon as you are accused something,
there's some cases where you're right,
it can't,
it's strictly a he said,
she said,
and you could find yourself,
uh,
in,
in a lot of trouble.
And that's obviously not okay.
I think the problem is you cannot be w w we,
we have a society that I think unfortunately discourages women from reporting,
from coming forward.
And I think that that's a serious problem because in,
in crimes like this,
a lot of the people who commit them can continue to commit them.
The rate of recidivism I think is,
is such that if they're not being reported,
you're going to see more victims,
unfortunately.
Well,
there's,
there's also,
without a doubt,
there's people that for whatever reason,
they don't look at other people as being equal to them,
you know,
and that,
that is what allows someone to rape someone.
That's what happens in this video.
She is a local girl.
She goes to Santa Fe community college as opposed to like,
you know,
the flagship state school that like the,
the quote rich had a town kids,
you know,
I'll go to,
and they treat her like,
you know,
the way they speak to her,
the way they speak to her.
And,
and it's a similar phenomenon in,
in,
in the Duke Lacrosse case is that that woman was black.
But here,
this
woman who was white and in this,
in this raw deal case,
uh,
but had black children,
the,
it's I think,
well,
what's,
what's the famous line from,
from Bulworth?
Um,
uh,
white people have more in common with black people than they do with rich
people.
Meaning the division is not so much black and white.
That's kind of a,
that's a flashy object to divide us and Torah and affluent.
Absolutely.
It's the haves and the have nots and the poor people get treated like shit no
matter what color.
But also people in that position,
people that are strippers,
you know,
because it's looked down upon as like a CD career choice of losers,
so you're allowed to treat her like shit.
And then she's in a fraternity,
which is not even a protected environment,
like an actual strip club and you're dealing with people that are drunk and
their judgments all fucked up because of that.
And then you know,
who knows?
Plus you're dealing with developing minds,
an 18 year old kids that are drunk,
they really shouldn't be drunk.
They don't know what the fuck they're doing.
And on top of that,
they'd probably been raised by assholes,
you know,
I mean there's a good percentage of people are assholes and these kids drunk in
some fucking thing,
feeding off of each other,
getting mentality,
which is peer pressure of that situation as is dead fucking terrible deadly gang
mentality that you see in riots,
gang mentality that you see in behavior that you would never see gangs or
behavior to the point of criminality because of the outside influence of what
everybody else doing it.
That's like a psychosis.
That's a crazy,
like what's going on in the brain?
Well,
it says,
it speaks to our weird,
uh,
the,
the way that human beings imitate our atmospheres,
which is like a big part of what we were talking about earlier about culture.
You get stuck in certain cultures and cultures where violence is accepted and
violence.
Like if you live in the Congo,
you know,
and you're,
you're in a tribe and you're,
you're,
there's a warlord,
you know,
and you're seeing people shot and killed all the time.
The [inaudible] 47 when you're five.
Yeah.
I mean it's just,
that's,
that's their environment.
I have to ask you this then,
because I mean,
you've talked about it a zillion times,
but like America's gun culture,
that's what everybody says.
America's propensity towards violence and proliferation of violence.
And you don't see this in other country because you don't see the quantity of
guns.
Yeah,
well,
it's an issue.
And the celebration of violence,
of course,
in our media and our,
our entertainment,
et Cetera,
that's an issue to the celebration and video games celebration and all those
things are unquestionably influences.
However,
if you look at the actual numbers of people that have guns,
which is fucking staggering,
and the actual crimes committed by those guns,
it's very small.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Which is undeniable.
And that's something that people don't like to bring up when they bring up a
Newtown massacre or something where you have massacres.
I believe those are issues of mental health without a doubt.
And I think absolutely,
you know,
I wrote that this country has a mental health problem disguised a gun problem
and a tyranny problem disguised as a security problem.
And I think that that is a real reality when it comes to guns and shooters and
mental issues.
And also the number of people that are involved in mass shootings that are on
psychoactive drugs,
anti psychotics,
auntie's impressions,
poison is what,
who knows?
But correlation does not equal causation.
Right.
So you don't know if those people were crazy already and they're giving them
drugs to try to treat them and maybe there would be better off.
Maybe it's getting off those drugs,
which is often the case.
The,
the,
the um,
um,
coming down off those drugs for all affects the withdraw.
The causes,
these people to go crazy.
There's a lot of issues,
but you can't deny that it's too fucking easy to get a gun.
You know,
you need a driver's license to get a fucking car.
All you need to do is not be a criminal to get a gun.
I mean,
I,
I bought a gun before I knew anything about guns.
I didn't know how to use them at all.
They just let me have a fucking pistol.
And I remember thinking it must have a hot dog stand for crying you to have a
permit to shovel snow.
Think Jersey.
I'm an,
I'm a nice person so I'm not going to go out and shoot people.
But I found it incredibly disturbing that it,
they didn't all,
they immediately know that I didn't,
wasn't a criminal.
I didn't commit any violent crimes.
And that's it.
That's all he needed to know.
And truth be told,
if you were a criminal when on the street to get it,
it would be even easier than he walked into because they don't want your
driver's license if you're buying them,
especially in this country at this point.
The numbers,
there's the sheer numbers.
Like I've heard it described,
like trying to get guns out of America was like trying to take salt out of the
ocean.
It's like Jesus Christ.
Like you're going to get all the salts out of the ocean.
There's more Americans with,
or there's more guns rather than there are Americans.
And in,
in America there's more guns.
Then there are people that's fucking crazy.
There's more than 350 million guns in this country.
That is hard to wrap your head around.
You know,
I,
I got two hands,
but the mail,
most of us have time.
I have more guns than I am people.
So I'm part of the problem.
But I'm not shooting anybody.
You're above average,
you know,
I only have,
I only have a couple.
So I just don't think that,
um,
that,
that I don't think that the issue is necessarily that there's a lot of guns.
The issue to me is we most certainly need a better education program when it
comes to the ability to acquire a gun.
They've,
they've,
the fact that you have to go through this,
you know,
difficult taxing process to get a car.
But I think people were afraid that like,
you know,
like they say that owning a car is a privilege on a gun as a right.
It's a right that's in the bill.
You know what I mean?
That's a,
it's in the bill of rights.
It's a second amendment in the constitution.
It says right to bear arms and there's,
there's people that are legitimately worried for good reason that a lot of
people have this knee jerk reaction when any sort of violent crime goes down to
take all the guns away from the p.
But I don't think that,
I don't know,
maybe having to take a shooting course is an impediment to your exercising of
that safety.
I'm a I,
my family,
I got family in Delaware and they grew up in gun culture,
a hunting culture
and about,
and there's some of the most responsible,
coolest,
best p,
you know,
they,
because it guns had been completely demystified for them.
They're not afraid.
They know how to properly use them and they're the least threatening,
most coolest,
most unassuming people that you could possibly.
But they're cool with any type of weapon that you,
that you know,
basically that you put in front,
not just guns,
but knives that they use for hunting.
And Evan and I were just like,
what if we all grew up like,
wouldn't it just be,
I think we'd all be nicer to each other to like,
we'd all be aware of sort of the power that we possess from the,
you know,
we're not just these sort of like TV gangsters or whatever.
We don't,
you know,
we,
we'd all just,
we'd almost be a little bit more cognizant of the fact that we have this w if we
choose to have the power of life and death over somebody,
but they also have it over us.
Well,
that's what's live and let live,
right?
And expression that a well armed society is a polite society.
And oftentimes that is true.
But the aberration,
the person who is not polite and decides to take out the fact that they have do,
do you remember that instance in north Hollywood years back when those guys got
the put on bulletproof vests and had all these crazy guns and they robbed a bank
record?
Yeah,
the heat was inspired by in crazy,
crazy scene.
I was doing news radio at the time and we all went into the break room and we're
all watching it on his television and we were all just like,
freaking the fuck out.
Like this is real.
This isn't a movie.
We're watching a shootout between the cops and these insane people with massive
firepower.
And those types of scenarios,
although incredibly rare,
are really legitimately frightening to people for a good reason.
That's what happened in,
in,
in Miami.
You remember the war wagon at the Dadeland mall shooting in July of 79 that we
opened cocaine cowboys.
When cops show up at this scene,
they have guns on the ground.
Uh,
and to be Canon,
the,
uh,
the reporter said,
they called them the dis,
the Dixie Cup generation.
They would shoot a gun until it was empty and then just drop it on the floor and
pull out another gun and shoot that.
And there were Mac eleven's and there were a hand guns and pistols and automatic
a pistols.
And they were just,
and they,
and there was a shell casings for every single gun on the ground.
They left the guns in the ground and then they took off on foot and they
abandoned this war wagon,
which was this converted 40 Econoline van that had stenciled on the side,
happy time,
party supply and a phone number.
And then the other side it said,
happy supply time in a different phone number on the other side,
not really good with the,
you know,
the,
the incognito thing here.
And in the back they had flak jackets that they had put that they had kind of
like wallpaper that width so that it would be like,
have reinforced bulletproof armor and more guns of every shotguns and machine
got.
So it was like the punishers war wagon.
Cops show up with their six shooters by the way,
cause that's what they were carrying in Miami in 1979.
And they flipped the fuck out.
And there was a,
every time someone saw 40 Connor line van,
like on the streets,
people were calling nine one one.
The cops wouldn't show like they didn't know what the hell to
do because they knew that the fear was you're gonna pull one of these over.
The back's going to open up and they're just going to empty,
empty on and before you can even grab your pop,
pop,
pop gun,
you know,
and that was when they started to put together the syntech 26,
the four.
There you go.
There's the back of it right there.
And,
and um,
they put together this,
uh,
sentec was a central central tactical unit that was made up of multiple local
and federal agencies that would work together.
The,
the history of which traces back to the untouchables.
Cause that was like we're going to come back to take the best of the local guys
and the best of the federal guys and put them together towards a kind of common,
very specific goal oriented mission and end.
And so you had these guys who got together because originally they were called
the,
uh,
it's in reloaded,
um,
uh,
the special homicide investigative team or as they call themselves the Shit
Squad special homicide investigative team.
And they had to deal with all the one dose that we're turning up because they'd
get,
they'd get an Oh God,
uh,
unidentified Hispanic male automatic bullet fire.
Is it 25% of the bodies in the Morgan that time in Miami had automatic wounds
from automatic weapons friend who was doing his residency,
he's a doctor or anything.
It was residency in Miami.
That was the best place to do it.
Oh my God.
He told me some shit and showed me some shit when we were growing up.
You know,
I was,
he's older than me.
And,
uh,
when he was showing us these images that he had saved from guys with light bulbs
up their asses and bullet hole in the trauma industry,
in the medical business,
the law enforcement business,
the homicide business journalism business like Miami was the place to be.
It was crazy.
The one I know a guy who was a,
who was a trauma doctor at Jackson Memorial Hospital in the,
in the,
that's our,
that's our one major trauma center where you know all the bullet,
you,
you get airlifted to Jackson,
that's where you go.
So he was working one night and this was after the Mariel boatlift.
It thinks Scarface,
like you had all of these hardened criminals.
The,
the,
the rejected from Cuba rate of rape on Miami beach quadrupled in months.
I mean,
they were raping little old Jewish ladies,
Holocaust survivors who made it out of Germany but could not survive the Mariel
boatlift in Miami.
And they all went to Miami beach because it was a slum.
And because you had the,
it reminded them of Havana,
it looked like Cuba,
Miami beach,
like,
Oh shit.
Like that sea wall.
And every,
it looks like Cuba,
so on and,
and they would just kill you for nothing.
They'd be like,
I like your bicycle.
Gimme your bicycle.
No,
boom,
and just end and then leave the bike until like,
like just crazy homicidal lunatics.
Um,
and uh,
they,
uh,
one guy,
one day,
Mariel,
Mariel Lito comes in with a gunshot wound and the doctor says to him,
he knew Spanish.
She said,
he said,
you're very lucky,
man.
Had the bullet struck you a centimeter or so over here,
you would have bled out and died on the scene.
And in minutes if not seconds,
um,
the guy gets discharged,
leaves the hospital,
uh,
within days he gets another Mariel gunshot victim with a wound in exactly the
same spot he told the other guy about and that guy died.
And his belief always was,
he never could prove it,
but that the guy,
he had told basically where to shoot the other guy that this was a retribution
shooting for the other guy who had been shot.
But like,
that was just par for the course.
And in Miami,
the girl who cuts my hair,
a lady who cuts my hair,
she,
you know how you get your hair cut,
you,
you say goodbye.
You put the tip in the,
in the pocket.
So she'd go would go home at night in the 80s and she'd turn her pockets inside
out to get all of the folded bills in this net.
One day she found,
finds a little Baggie with white powder in it that one of the ladies just
saying,
kissed her goodbye and slipped it in their pocket as a tip.
And,
and she,
she said,
I was so naive.
I said to my friend,
what the hell is this?
And she said,
what it is is worth more than the tip that you would have that you would have
gotten from the same ladies.
Wow.
That's what that was.
That's a,
that's our enemy.
That's our Emmy.
Keep it in.
Keep that place.
I visit your loss and your,
your Los Angeles.
You can have it.
I visit and I get the fuck out again.
Billy.
Thank you very much man.
It's a lot of fun.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you.
Documentary Dogfighting,
d a w g.com coming March 12th March 12th and cocaine cowboys one and two.
Don't listen to him too is good.
It's very good.
Don't apologize.
It's one,
one of the best documentaries ever that captures the madness of,
of,
of cocaine really.
I mean,
and,
and violence and the drug war.
I mean,
it's just an amazing documentary.
Thank you very much,
Billy Corbin.
Ladies and gentlemen.
We'll see you next week.
Good night.
Everybody.
Much love.
Yeah.